hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and this is going to be one of those
podcast episodes that people have been
clamoring for
for a long time i get a lot of
suggestions and a lot of people suggest
the same guest over and over again
sometimes i ignore the people you know i
love the people but i don't always agree
with them
other times i think you know what the
people are right and in this case i
think that they are
so i invited stephen wolfram to be on
the podcast now
stephen wolfram was a physics prodigy at
a young age one of the youngest winners
of the macarthur
genius grant started out in particle
physics before he moved to think about
complexity and cellular automata maybe
best known right now for inventing the
mathematica
programming language and analysis system
as well as the underlying
wolfram language that was used to write
it and wolfram alpha
answer engine i use mathematical all the
time many people in my field use
mathematica
but he's also still interested in
fundamental physics
a few years ago some years ago he wrote
a big book called a new kind of science
where he suggested that cellular
automata
might give a clue as to different ways
of thinking about
all sorts of science right biology
economics as well as physics
more recently he has launched what is
called the wolfram physics project
which is simply an effort to start with
almost nothing and get the fundamental
laws of physics
out of them now there's a lot to say
about this
um and we don't say everything in this
podcast even though it's a long one i
wanted to focus
the podcast on giving a sketch for what
the main ideas are
of the wolfram physics project and how
they are not yet
fully developed but might be developed
going down the line
there were a lot of criticisms and some
uh kudos
about how he developed it sort of
outside the mainstream
of physics research and so forth and
then you know
laid on us hundreds of pages of work
with he and his collaborators at the
same time
and you know it's not the mainstream of
theoretical physics most physicists who
are doing their own thing did not drop
everything to work on it but some became
interested and they're inviting people
to help out um so you'll learn a lot in
this podcast
not about i'm not going to talk about
you know how the research was done
or the fact that it was uploaded and
shared with the world or whatever you
can draw your own conclusions about that
i care about the substance of the actual
ideas
and mostly i'm giving steven here the
opportunity to explain
those ideas but there is a family
resemblance between what he's trying to
do
and what i and my collaborators are
trying to do in quantum mechanics
stuff like that so let me very briefly
tell you what i how i see
that relationship um what we're trying
to do is to start with
the simplest most stripped-down version
of the best theory we currently
understand namely quantum mechanics
right
to start from almost nothing but quantum
mechanics and see how things like
space and time and matter and energy
emerge from that fundamental description
stephen wolfram and his friends are
trying to be way more ambitious
than that they're starting with a kind
of
automata a kind of discrete system
called a hypergraph
and generalizations thereof and
basically
you have a guess as to what the rules
are for how hyper graphs are updated
and the point that they're trying to
make is that some guesses
lead to things that kind of look like
the real world so the hope is
that eventually we find specific guesses
for what those update rules could be
that actually get us the specific real
world or very very close
to it my own attitude is you know good
luck to them i'm
very much in favor of lots of different
approaches to fundamental physics
this is one of them great let a thousand
flowers bloom et cetera
i actually think that our my and my
collaborators
approach is more promising because it
leans heavily on something we already
understand
quite well which is quantum mechanics as
i see it
if the wolfram physics project works
they're
first going to have to find quantum
mechanics in exactly the right way
and then find all the features that we
have about the real world so it's kind
of a
precursor to what i'm trying to do etc
but you know i might be wrong about that
it could be that this particular way of
doing things
leads to not just quantum mechanics but
a specific implementation of quantum
mechanics that gives us other clues to
understand the nature of space and time
etc so as i said what we're trying to do
here in this podcast is help you the
listener
actually understand what the ideas are
and where they're going hopefully we
succeed in that
let me very briefly take an opportunity
to as i occasionally do
remind you that we have resources for
the mindscape podcast
we have a web page
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
so every episode has you know links to
stuff about the authors and other
resources and
also full transcripts of the complete
episode so you can search
every mindscape episode for the last
three years we're hitting our
three year anniversary roughly speaking
and also we have a patreon
if you would like to support mindscape
you can go to patreon.com
sean m carroll donate a dollar or two or
whatever your local currency is
uh per episode and you get ad-free
versions of the podcast as well as the
ability to ask questions in our monthly
ask me anything episodes mostly it's
about gratitude
uh i'm i'm very happy very um pleased
that so many people
enjoy minescape very much and therefore
choose to donate just a little bit it's
the thought that really does count in
this case
uh so with all that let's go
[Music]
stephen wolf and welcome to the
mindscape podcast hello
so it's been a little over a year i
guess since you announced your
physics project and i think i finally
by no means have become an expert but at
least i know enough about it
to ask a whole bunch of ignorant
questions to help us all understand it a
little bit
better um i mean maybe to start off
is this do you consider this current
project be a continuation
of the cellular automata type of stuff
you did in your book a new kind of
science or is it a
new branch somehow yeah so i mean it
builds on
basically a tower of ideas technology
intuition and so on that uh
actually i'm sort of amazed we managed
to get to the point we've managed to get
to
but all those previous pieces seem to be
necessary to get to where we are
and for example you know i studied a lot
in new kind of science 20 years ago
i studied a lot of cellular automata
which are these very
simple programs with you know arrays of
black and white squares and so on
and from studying those things i
developed both a bunch of intuition
about how sort of things
work in the computational universe and i
managed to figure out some fairly
general principles which we've been able
to get more and more evidence for
which are necessary to kind of launch
into
figuring out things about physics now
when i wrote new kind of science
you know it has 12 chapters and one of
those chapters was called fundamental
physics
and it had two sections one was about
thermodynamics and one was about
kind of the fundamental underlying
theory of physics and for me at the time
i viewed it as being
an incomplete potential application
of the general kinds of ideas that i was
developing a new kind of science
and i had a bunch of specific ideas
about thinking about space
as a network thinking about the way time
would operate and so on
um i was very pleased with the fact that
i had managed to get a fair distance and
deriving general relativity from that
kind of theory of gravity from that kind
of approach
i was not satisfied with where i had got
with quantum mechanics
and you know that project so so now
restarting that project nearly 20 years
later
um with uh energetic young physicists
and so on
and uh one kind of initially rather
technical new idea
that kind of made the model just seem
much cleaner to me
it was kind of it's been a new
development and and really
now i've seen a lot of things that i say
to myself
i should have been able to figure that
out 25 years ago welcome to the club
that does not distinguish you from
anyone else working on science right
yeah you always look back
with that no i i think i think what's
what's some so i view it as being
what's really neat is that the formalism
that we've now got
is something which was sort of there
were precursors of it in new kind of
science
but the full sort of story of it is just
emerging now
and it's really neat because it really
it gives one sort of a
to me there's sort of this way of
understanding things in terms of how
simple programs behave
developed a bunch of intuition a new
kind of science now there's a whole
nother level of intuition
and results that we're getting that
provide in the sort of formalism for
this project and that's
it's it's both applicable to fundamental
physics and to a bunch of other things
and i'm i'm pretty excited about that so
let's imagine that
first i'm sure this is not true but
let's imagine that there's going to be a
listener
who only listens to the first few
minutes of this podcast we want to
let them have a takeaway for what is
going on here i mean is it accurate
my vague impression to say that the
cellular automata
uh had a grid right like you had some
checkerboard or something like that and
some rules for updating them and some
discrete
model which you're going to hope that if
you squint and look at very far away it
looks like physics
whereas here you still have a discrete
set of models but you're not starting
with a fixed grid you're kind of
building things up by rules as you go
right yeah that's right i mean i never
thought that
that cellular automata would be relevant
to fundamental physics
i mean other people were sort of saying
cellular automata are going to solve
fundamental physics
and i was like no please don't say that
that's just not going to work
and um you know cellular automata are
very minimal models once you have a
fixed notion of space and time
and they've been extremely fertile
models for huge numbers of different
kinds of things from you know road
traffic flow
to chemical catalysis to you know leaf
growth
all kinds of different things but they
assume
a pre-existing notion of space and time
and so in thinking about physics
i had realized ages ago that we really
need to go underneath the notions of
space and time that we're familiar with
and see how to build those up from
something more fundamental and so sort
of the real starting point of our
project
is to think about just these they're
just
space is made of something that's not a
that has not been
sort of in the tradition of physics and
the traditional mathematics as well
that's not really been a thing that
people think about space just is a
is is something in which peop things are
placed at certain positions and so on
and so you know in this and it's kind of
like what people might have thought
about a fluid like water
it's just water it's just flows it does
all these kinds of things but you know
150 years ago
we found out no those greeks were
actually right some of those greeks were
right
it's made of discrete molecules bouncing
around
and with space we haven't yet sort of
made that definitive leap and one of the
sort of starting points of this project
is to think space is made of something
what's it made of
it's just made of these disembodied
discrete points
and each point is just an abstract
element it doesn't it doesn't
have a position there's nothing it's
just this element
and then what we say is what all we know
about those elements
is how they're related to other elements
how they're effectively connected to
other elements so it's like
you think about all these points in
space all they have is a friend network
so to speak
they don't know where they are they just
know who their friends are so to speak
and so the you know the first big sort
of
realization is from something as
unstructured as that
by looking at that on a large enough
scale it's kind of like how you know
continuous fluids emerge
from lots of discrete molecules
underneath bouncing around there's a
there's a notion of a kind of continuous
like space that can emerge when you look
at that on a large scale
and that's that's kind of the you know
that's that's one starting point i mean
another important thing to realize
is that in our setup
the only thing in the universe is space
and there's no uh you know we're not
saying
space is a background and there are
things placed in space
we're saying everything in the universe
is just kind of made of space
so what i have in mind is a bunch of
dots right nodes that are connected by
lines to form some kind of graph
and do i imagine that the line that the
dots rather the nodes are they
labeled do they come are there different
kinds of dots or is there just a an er
dotness that they all share it's an
ur dot okay that's just they're all
identical the only thing
the only thing about them is they are
two dots are either identical or they're
not identical that is there's
there's a there's a particular dot or
there's another dot
and so the only the only thing about
them is is kind of their
their you know their identity so to
speak
they don't have that they don't have
colors they don't have
they don't have uh positions they just
know
i'm this dot and not that other dot
right so there's some dots and there's
some lines they make a graph or a hyper
graph i guess
then there's a rule there's a rule for
updating to go from one collection of
dots and lines to
the next one and then we just iterate
that forever i suppose
that's right and the whole universe
comes out of that it's very nice
that that's the idea so i mean you know
there are many pieces
to that setup for example one thing is
all there
is is these kind of atoms of space and
connections
there's nothing in space there's nothing
it's not like you then
say we've got space now let's put a
an electron in space if you want an
electron you have to make it out of
space so to speak
you have to make it from features of
that pattern of connections
between the atoms of space so that's
kind of the that's that's sort of the
the base story of what what is the data
structure of the universe what is the
universe
sort of made of and that's the idea it's
made of these
discrete elements and relations between
those elements
which we can think of as being kind of
lines joining them
it's actually convenient and this was
the sort of technical innovation of a
couple of years ago
to realize that the best way to think
about this is in terms of
a so-called hypergraph where we just
have elements and relations
in a graph you have you have nodes and
you have edges connecting those nodes
and each edge connects two nodes in a
hypergraph
you can have any number of nodes
involved in a hyperedge and that sounds
like a
it is really a technical detail but it
makes the whole
model much much easier to deal with or
at least i thought it made it much
easier to deal with
in the end it doesn't make much of a
difference and i could have figured this
out 25 years ago
but that's that's that's the uh that's
the way these things work it it seemed
to make it easier technically to make
forward progress
but i think you were then talking about
sort of what do these
what do these atoms of space do and
you're describing kind of the rules that
they use
to get updated and um yeah you're right
i mean
the basic idea is you look at the local
structure of this graph
and you say whenever the local structure
of this graph looks
like this particular pattern then it
should be updated
to be a local piece of graph that looks
different right
and that's the whole story
some things are just better at home you
can pause the movie whenever you want
you can have two desserts and no one
will judge you
and exercise is one of those things
peloton
delivers a workout experience that you'd
never imagine was possible
right in your own home one of the things
i especially like about peloton is the
variety of classes driven by different
kinds of instructors
if you're the kind of person who needs
to be encouraged by your instructor
robin arzone is especially good at that
whereas
if you just want to get down to business
and get the workout in adrian williams
might be the instructor for you
whatever your mood or overall fitness
goal you can mix and match classes for a
total body workout experience
choose from cardio strength yoga pilates
outdoor runs
meditation and more with the peloton
bike there's nothing like working out
from home
learn more at onepeloton.com new members
can try peloton classes free for 30 days
at onepeloton.com
app terms apply that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n
i like i like the fact that you just use
the word hypergraph because i like to
share the jargon with the audience so
they can go look it up because
especially i mean i should note you um i
don't want to talk too much about like
style and procedure here because there's
far too much physics to talk about but
you did announce this project with a
website
and a call to uh participate right if
people want to
dig into the details what is the url
they should be going to
well from physics.org there you go and
and people can
find out what the details are and do
their own calculations so that's that's
it yeah i mean the other thing we've
done
kind of in terms of the public which has
been really a big success
is we've we've live streamed a lot of
our internal working meetings
and we've uh you know all the notes from
this project
are all you know posted on the web
basically the
the day after they're made typically and
that's um
and and it's been really interesting
because a lot of people
who are you know a lot of professional
physicists have gotten involved but also
a lot of people
who are for example involved in computer
kinds of things
and understand sometimes more of some of
our jargon
than the physicists would understand
i've also gotten involved
and it's it's really been an interesting
process to to sort of
do science live and in public so to
speak um
it's uh you know and i i the the it's
like
uh it um it's a good kind of generator
of of reality because you know we say
some things that are right we say some
things that are wrong
it's kind of a a place where you can get
to see
kind of uh the process really happen and
there is something that is very
different about what you're trying to do
in terms of fundamental
physics i i would i would argue and then
correct me if i'm wrong
usually not always but usually
physicists work
from the phenomena to try to come up
with an explanation right like there are
stars in the sky there are planets
moving in certain orbits what can we do
about that there's an apple falling from
a tree
but in some sense you're just saying
well here's the simplest possible thing
that physics
could be let's just see if we can guess
the right one is that
more or less accurate yeah i mean it is
closer to that
than the reverse engineering approach
and in fact when i see people try to
sort of understand what we're doing
and uh sort of say well what about doing
this and that and the other
the great tendency is to try to reverse
engineer and this was a thing that that
i kind of uh
you know i as you know i i used to do
sort of
mainstream standard physics back in the
late 1970s early 1980s
and you know that was what one did in
those days
and the thing that was really for me
very liberating was
when i started studying well i got
interested in how did complex phenomena
occur in the natural world
and the question was what are the right
models to study that
and my initial thought was let's use all
the fancy stuff from physics all those
differential equations and all these
kinds of things
i tried doing that total failure so i
said let's
step back and see you know is there an
alternative approach to modeling that we
can use
and i had the very fortunate experience
that i had been
working as a practical matter on
building my first
computer language as a forerunner of
mathematical multilanguage
um this was back in 1979 1980 and
what one does one one builds a computer
language is one
saying let's take all these computations
people might want to do
unless in a kind of natural science type
way drill down and try and find out
what are the primitives from which we
can build up all these computations
what are the kind of atoms of
computation and then build up from there
and the thing that's really interesting
about that process is you're just making
up these atoms of computation
it's not like you know it's not really
the same kind of oh we've also we've got
to make sure we get
you know einstein's equations here we've
got to do this and this you're just
making it up and you're hoping that it
will be
in that case useful to people and so
that experience got me into this idea of
just figure out the most minimal model
and see what it does
and that's what i did with cellular
automata and it worked great in that
case
so in a sense with physics what i was
trying to do
with this project is find the most
structuralist model
of structure in the universe because
that was
and and it is not it is by no means
self-evident that that will work
i mean that's sort of the ultimate
occam's razor type idea
is you know just make it you know
absolutely minimal
now the thing that's really neat and
maybe we'll talk about this a bunch
later
is that now that we have this foundation
we can start to see how a lot of ideas
that people have had in mathematical
physics
over the last many decades actually plug
into this idea
and both inform it and help make those
other ideas more
more you know founded and it's it's i
think
um uh so so this
this notion which basically you know
this idea of find the simplest
primitives and then see what they do
this is what i get for having spent 40
years being a computational language
designer
this is what that's what that's what
that involves and it's different
from what people do traditionally in
sort of
reductionistic science where you say
start from the phenomena and then say
how do i get this phenomenon
right and and i do want to get a
somewhat different methodology
i do want to definitely get to how we
recover all of known physics or at least
you know
move in the direction of recovering all
of known physics but there also seems to
be like a couple of
deep principles uh that you have in mind
when you're working on this stuff that
maybe it's worth sharing i mean one of
them is this
idea of computational equivalence right
uh
i i could try to gloss it but why don't
you tell the audience what that means
yeah yeah right so you know you
set up some simple program you run it
you see what it does
you might think if it's a simple program
it will always do simple things
that turns out to not be true that's
sort of the big thing that i discovered
in the early 1980s
that for several years i kind of
resisted that conclusion
and eventually realized that is really
the way things are when you look in the
sort of computational universe of
possible programs
if you just sort of pick a program at
random even though the program may be
very simple its behavior may be very
complicated
programs that we typically build as
humans for some particular known purpose
will tend to not have that feature
because we want to have them achieve the
particular purpose we want them to
achieve
which is one some purpose that we can
describe and so you avoid
this thing that the simple programs
producing complicated behavior
that idea of simple programs producing
complicated behavior
i think is sort of the essence of the
secret that nature uses
to make complicated stuff and that's why
you know we look around in nature we
steal this complicated stuff we say how
could it possibly make all this
complicated stuff
that's just the formal fact about what
happens
in the universe of possible programs so
the first thing is is the realization
simple program doesn't necessarily have
to have simple behavior
and then the next question is okay so
you see this very complicated behavior
how do you characterize it you could
just say oh it's very complicated
and in fact a lot of the you know people
had seen
these phenomena for centuries actually
of you know
fairly simple setups like you know the
digits of pi
specifying them is quite easy yet once
you've generated the digits
they seem completely random and people
would typically say
oh it's very complicated there's not
much we can say about that
and they would try to find you know like
the distribution of prime numbers or
something they
worked for a long time to try and figure
out what regularity can we tease out of
this thing that seems quite random
and so what i was interested in was
trying to understand how do we
characterize
this complexity that gets generated and
so the thing that i realized is
the way you can think about what's
happening is any process of generating
some pattern for example
you can think of as a computation and
then the question is
how sophisticated is that computation so
for example
it might be that computation is just
like adding numbers
together it's something very simple or
that computation is something more
sophisticated
and the question is can you kind of can
you rate
these sort of sophistication of
computations and so
the big discovery of the 1930s and so on
was
that you might have thought every
different kind of computation you want
to do
you'd need a different machine to do it
but then with turing machines and
combinators and a bunch of other ideas
this notion of universal computation
arose that says
you can just have one piece of hardware
and just feed it different programs
and it can do different things and you
know that's been a that's been a pretty
centrally important idea in the
technology of the last fifteen years
you know that's the origin of software
that the the development of the
computer revolution but in for science
the implication there is well perhaps
these
simple programs might actually be for
example computation universal they might
be able to
do essentially any computation you want
so this principle of computational
equivalence of mind is basically the
the idea that when you pick a program
if the program doesn't do something
obviously simple
it will be doing a computation that is
as sophisticated as the computations
that anything can do
so in other words what that's saying is
you know you might think
you start off with an incredibly trivial
program it only has trivial computations
as you make the program a little bit
more complicated it would gradually
do more and more sophisticated
computations and as you make a really
really really complicated program
it would do really really complicated
computations but the the
the somewhat surprising claim of the
principle of computational equivalence
was that that's not true
once you get above some very low
threshold you're immediately at the max
you're immediately doing computations
that are as sophisticated as anything
and that that principle i mean that has
that principle has many
implications and um i mean probably the
most important
for for immediately for physics is this
phenomenon i call computational
irritability
that was the next one so go ahead and
say that yeah
right so so i mean the um you know the
question there is
if you are running a program can you
tell what it will do
one way you can tell what it will do is
you just run every step
like the program would run itself but
another thing you can do is say
i'm much smarter than that program i can
jump ahead
and it's going to run for a million
steps but i can just jump to the end and
say
the answer is going to be 42 or
something and um
so you know one of the ideas of of sort
of the exact sciences the mathematical
scientists for a long time has been
sort of a sign of doing wonderful things
is that you can jump ahead like that you
can make
you can readily predict you know where
will the planets be at some time in the
future and so on
but so that's that's what i call
computational reusability the ability to
reduce the computational effort
necessary to find the answer to jump
ahead
so the claim is actually there are lots
of systems that are computationally
irreducible
in the sense the only way to find out
what they'll do is just to run every
step or in effect just to observe what
the system does
and the reason that happens is because
of the principle of computational
equivalence
because if you think you're the observer
you're the predictor
you are a com you are a computational
system as well and the question is
how do you as a computational system
compete with the system you're trying to
predict
so if it was the case that you could
really be smarter than the system you're
trying to predict
then yes you could potentially jump
ahead but what the principle of
computational equivalent says
is no actually that won't be that way
you will be exactly computationally
equivalent
to the system you're trying to predict
and so the system you're trying to
predict
its behavior will seem to you sort of
irreducibly complicated
so that's that's one of its implications
so in some sense this is saying
you know both of these principles the
equivalence and the irreducibility
um there are computers as we've known
since touring that are universal
computers they can calculate any
function you want to calculate
and what you're saying is in the space
of all computers computations
uh computations with that capacity
are generic in some sense they're all
over the place they're much easier to
find than you might have thought
and there's no way to simplify the the
typical one into
uh something that you can just leap
ahead right i mean
principle of computational equivalence
one of its predictions in effect
is that universal computation will be
ubiquitous it actually goes considerably
further than that because
at a technical level one of the things
that one talks about in universal
computation is
it is possible to program this system to
do whatever computation you want
it's a little bit of a different
statement to say if you are presented
with this system
and it is fed this even this very simple
program
then it will already do something
complicated so it's a couple a couple of
additional steps yeah one of the
one of the key predictions is
computational universality is ubiquitous
and that that has many implications i
mean it has implications in terms of the
practicalities of building computers
it has implications in terms of what
aspects of physics we can expect to
understand
it has implications at a more
philosophical level about things like
free will and so on which maybe we'll
talk about
well and one of the implications is that
it it if we buy into the philosophy of
it it gives us some optimism for this
program of
starting program in the human sense not
the computer sense
for this uh project of starting with
some very very simple rules and getting
the actual universe out right if
all sufficiently complicated
computations are at the same level of uh
ability in some sense yes that's true i
mean one of the things that is sort of a
key
i would you could even say prediction
statement of our physics project
is what can be done in our universe is
just computation
and not hyper computation that is it's
the kind of computation that can be done
by a turing machine
it's not the kind of computation that
can be done by a thing that is
infinitely more powerful than a turing
machine
right that you can conceptually imagine
but you can't uh you know the claim is
no such thing exists in our universe
and in fact you can get a bit more
technical about it and
the the claim of these models is even if
it exists
it will be hidden by behind a
chronological event horizon
from us um we will never be able to
observe it so it's kind of like well you
can say it exists so you can say it
doesn't exist doesn't really matter
because we'll never be able to interact
with it but so you know that's one of
the
the key statements yes and and the idea
that
that it's sufficient to have something
uh that is a simple
a computational system that we humans
can kind of understand how it's
constructed like a turing machine
or like one of these hypergraph
rewriting systems that is a
you know that's a that's a supposition
of this project and it's a supposition
that
in a sense is is sort of encouraging for
us humans that
that it might be the case there's
something we can kind of hold in our
hands
that represents everything the universe
does even if
the implications of that thing we can
hold in our hands are irreducibly
complex
and even if we couldn't tell you know
given that you
give us the rules for the universe if
you say can i make a warp drive
the answer might be it's really hard to
tell it's an irreducibly complicated
thing
yeah it's like you know recapitulating
the whole history of mathematics and so
on to get to the point you know
can we prove this theorem that there is
or isn't a warp drive
um so it's uh but but to me that's yes
that that's
um that's that's the concept i'll take
all the reasons for optimism i can get
i'm all on board with that so
so good so with those in mind i mean
let's go back to the physics uh that
you're actually constructing here we
have a hyper graph
we have some rules for updating it now
should i read
the specific is it is the idea that
there's a specific correct rule for our
universe and that rule basically
is the fundamental laws of physics
okay so this this is where things get a
little bit more complicated yeah
so i think that it is probably the case
that there will be a rule that we'll be
able to hold up and say
with this rule we can reproduce what we
observe in physics
now footnote which is really interesting
footnote i think
you might say why did we get this rule
and not another rule
you know it seems very particularly if
the rule is simple that's like
you know copernicus was wrong so to
speak you know there isn't
nothing special about us we got the
simple universe so to speak
we got the universe with the simple rule
not the universe with the
to us incredibly complicated seeming
rule so
the the thing that is then very
surprising is that
and this is you know we probably have to
go a few more steps before we can really
really dig into this properly is the
idea that actually you can think of the
universe
as running all possible rules and we
as observers of the universe are
essentially exist
in a particular in a sense reference
frame in a particular
position in rule space as we call it
that
essentially gives us a particular
sampling of this
sort of universal possible and that
particular sampling
has is is given our
way of parsing what happens in the
universe
that is something that we could
attribute to a particular underlying
rule
but actually we can also think of it as
just a slice
of this kind of universal possible
universes so
it's a little bit more but but i think
you know operationally
i would hope that we will be able to
produce a rule that will have the
property that
if we work out all its consequences and
we cannot because remember
one of the very tricky things is we as
observers of the universe are embedded
in this universe
and so as you change that underlying
rule you not only change the rule for
the universe
you also change the rule for us and so
that those two effects in some very very
vague sense
cancel each other out so that there is a
large class of rules for the universe
and rules for us
which all seem the same and which which
all have the same laws of physics
effectively
so to give an analogy to make this a
little bit less less bizarre
the you know so let's go back to fluid
dynamics for example
and you know we have laws of fluid
dynamics they're the navier-stokes
equations all these kinds of things
and you might say how do we derive these
underneath there are a bunch of
molecules bouncing around
well there can be water molecules which
have their particular you know h2o form
there can be you know air molecules
there you know n2 or whatever it is
these different kinds of molecules
bouncing around
all of their physics is quite different
all the details of what happens when
those molecules
collide is quite different yet on a
large scale the laws of fluid dynamics
are the same
for air and for water they have some
different parameters but they're
basically the same laws
and it's the same kind of thing that i
think happens
in the derivation of laws of physics
that is
certain aspects of the laws of physics
are quite generic
i think general relativity and quantum
mechanics are quite generic
and they're things which if you are an
observer
even vaguely like us they are inevitable
that you will observe
and if you want to home in on well do we
have the fine structure constant with a
particular value it has
you probably have to home in on more
features of us as observers
right i mean do you think that do you
anticipate that at some step in
understanding the relationship between
these rules in our universe
there will be an anthropic move of some
sort where you say
there's a lot of things going on but
intelligent observers will only observe
this subset of things
intelligent observers know observers
with so the question is what is the
right idealization of the human observer
right so i'll give you a couple that um
that seem to be enough okay so one
important
one is we're computationally bounded we
don't get
to observe so let's take the gas
molecule example again
if if you are you know you have this gas
it's got a bunch of molecules bouncing
around
if you're a sophisticated enough
observer you can see every single
molecule you can work out all the
collisions
and in particular that will allow you so
you know a big principle of statistical
mechanics is the second law of
thermodynamics
which says you know typically the the
sort of typically things get more random
as the molecules bounce around in a gas
but if we are not computationally
bounded observers
and we can you know we can figure out
what all these trajectories of all these
molecules are
we don't get the second rule of
thermodynamics as non-computationally
bounded observers
the second order of thermodynamics
simply isn't true and so
the first and that same idea of a
computationally bounded observer
is necessary i think for us to believe
that space
has a continuous structure and various
other things about the universe
so that's kind of step one so we're not
laplace's demon
what's that sorry we're not laplace's
demon that is correct
we are not we're not laplace we're not
maxwell's demon
we're we're um uh we are we are we are
thoroughly non-demonic right
sensory and finite imbalance we only
have this sort of bounded ability to
unders
to look at the details of the universe
that's step one step two i've understood
more recently actually
and step two is something which i think
is sort of the
the physics essence of consciousness
which is
that we have this idea that there is a
single thread of experience that we
that we have it might not be that way
that is in the universe and we didn't
talk about this in detail yet but in the
universe all these little updatings
are happening all over the universe but
we
think that in a sense there's sort of
microscopic pieces of time
happening all over the universe but we
believe
we have a single identity through time
and that there is a single thread of
experience that we have through time
now it's it's by no means self-evident
that that would be the way it is because
in our model of physics everything about
the universe is being rewritten
you know 10 to the 100 times the
swapping or something like this
and so the fact that we have the idea
that we are still the same us a second
later
is non-trivial and so i think that an
observer who has that idea that there's
a single thread of time
has that is that is the one of the
things that you need in order to get the
laws of physics that we humans observe
and i think that's a so there's this
idea of we maintain our identity through
time
yeah which we might not um and the thing
i realized actually even more recently
although i should have realized this
earlier
is there's a similar idea for space it
is not
self-evident that there is a notion of
pure motion
so in other words you take an object you
move it somewhere else
in our models you know i take an object
i move it somewhere else
it's made of different atoms of space by
the time it gets to its destination
probably
and so then the question is how come
there's an idea of pure emotion
how come a thing can just be moved
without changing now obviously we know
in general utility you know
you're close to a black hole funky thing
can happen to you
if you move because the structure of
space is changing
but this is a a very basic fact that
most of the time
you know something moves and it is still
the same thing
and so this idea of this sort of this
this single thread of experience and
time
that the idea that it is possible to
have pure motion and it's possible to
maintain your identity
as you move around in space those two
attributes
seem to be what you need to derive
generic global physics
that is that's what you seem to need to
derive general relativity in quantum
mechanics
now if you start asking why does the
electron mass come out to be the actual
value it has
for us humans we probably need a little
bit more information about us humans to
be able to figure that out
that's i think i'm not sure right i mean
for example one of the things that the
current
challenge is the the local symmetry
groups local gauge groups
um it is looking very likely that it is
an inevitable
feature of our models that there will be
local gauging variants
and the thing that looks conceivable i
don't know yet
is that the actual uh gauge group will
be determined
so in other words even though we don't
yet know why the universe has three
dimensions
we might actually know why the internal
symmetry group is maybe a subgroup of e8
or whatever it is
before we even know this thing about
about about space
and so that would be an example but we
don't know you know if you ask what's
the electron muon mass ratio
you know we're we're still a fair
distance away from figuring that out
my expectation would be that there'll be
a particular rule
that we'll find which will have where a
whole bunch of those things will come
out
and one of the features if you believe
that the rule is simple is if you move
from one simple rule to another nearby
simple rule
everything's going to change because
there just aren't very many rules
that are that simple and so instead of
having you know electron muon mass ratio
it'll be
well there actually are an infinite
number of generations of particles and
there are
you know a bizarre number of dimensions
of space and all this kind of thing
it'll just be completely different
um but that's that's the current
expectation i think you
you raised the anthropic principle and
to me the anthropic principle is sort of
a story of
of lack of imagination so to speak
because
it's saying you know the only way that
we can have life intelligence
consciousness whatever
is the particular way we've seen it and
you know i i my one of the consequences
of this principle of computational
equivalence
is that actually something like
intelligence is ubiquitous
that is you might have thought to get
something as computationally
sophisticated as us humans with our
brains
and all this kind of thing you need the
whole process that's led to us humans
but what the principle of computational
equivalence says is that's not true
even these very simple systems with very
simple rules can do it
and that has well has lots of
consequences you know if you're if
you're worrying about extraterrestrial
intelligence for example that tells you
it's everywhere it's a question of
whether we are sufficiently aligned
with that intelligence to be able to
recognize it as something that for
example has purposes that we can
understand as sort of human-like
purposes so you know it's a
and i i think this idea intelligence
requires liquid water
is almost laughable i'm on your side
when it comes to that but but
intelligence might require space time in
some sense so let's let's at least
try to get that i mean do i is this
naive picture that i have in mind where
you have the hyper graph
you update uh it's a discrete updating
should i can i think of
the graph at any one update as space and
the
update itself as time or is that too
simple-minded
okay so it gets a little complicated and
in fact the complexity of the rises
is quantum mechanics i think and so it's
in a sense you try and make it
that simple and you
okay so so the basic point is the sort
of the rule says
if you have a lump of of atoms of space
that are connected in this way
transform it into a lump that's
connected in this other way
and it basically the rule just says
that's what you do it doesn't say where
you do it
doesn't say when you do it it's just any
time there's a lump that looks like this
you can transform it into a lump that
looks like that and so
those transformations can be happening
all over this hypograph
and so it is not at all obvious that
that is the only thing that's defined as
these can happen
the question of when they happen what
counts as the sort of simultaneity
surface
what counts as that moment in time is
something that's really in the eye of
the observer
okay so but the updated graph is
supposed to represent space time and the
things within it or is it a more subtle
map there
no no so so so at any given
what's happening is this graph is
getting updated and there are lots of
little places where it can get updated
and you can say okay i'm going to
consider the graph with this collection
of updates having been done
i am going to consider that as time t
equals zero let's say
and then another situation you're saying
gonna say
now i'm going to say this collection of
updates is time t equals one for example
and each one of those time slices at
each one of those sort of
well in in the language of physics space
like hypersurfaces
um the uh uh you know that represents
an instantaneous structure of space but
it is somewhat arbitrary
what you consider to be this
instantaneous sort of structure of space
just as it is in general well sure right
that's that's very familiar from general
relativity but i'm just saying is the
collection of the whole shebang
space time and the things without it
it's just space
a single hyper graph a single the
collection of all the updated hyper
graphs that's what i'm asking oh yeah
yeah
yeah right the the sequence of updates
the hyper graph
together with all its updates is
supposed to be space time
okay and and one of the things that is
is interesting and non-trivial here
is you know a lot of most traditional
views of physics have
thought of space and time as being the
same kind of thing in this model they're
really not
sure spaced is the extent of the spatial
hypograph
time is the computational process of
updating this hyper graph
so time is a time is the is the
progression of a computation
space is just oh you follow these these
connections in the hypergraph
okay and so that makes it not at all
obvious that you're going to get things
like relativity
out of the model because it's um uh you
know because one is
breaking apart the sort of traditional
connection between space and time
but it does so you say that the whole
the whole shebang is space time
one of the reasons i hesitated a little
bit about that is
the shebang is made by a computationally
irreducible process
so we don't get to it is a you know to
say let's just
unroll the whole structure of the
universe forever
well we don't get to do that in the
universe i mean the universe will do
that as the universe does it
but we can't just say this is what's
going to happen
because there is this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
but i do want to just distinguish
between this idea and is something
that someone like myself would be very
fond of which is some combination of
quantum gravity
and everetti in many worlds where there
are different branches of the wave
function where the geometry of
space-time is just different perhaps
radically different it sounds like
that is not something that is coming out
of your hyper graphs oh no no that that
will come out
i i i okay i was simplifying a bit okay
okay so what's happening is at every
you know these updates they get they
you're just saying
whenever you see a piece of hypograph
that looks like this you can do an
update
okay there are many possible sequences
of updates
that there are many possible sequencings
of these updates that could occur
each one of those sequencings defines
a different path of history effectively
now the non-trivial fact another
additional piece
is this thing we call causal invariance
and so what's happening is
if you look at this um uh this
okay so if you if you look at this this
hypograph and you imagine
you roll up the whole universe into a
single lump that you can kind of hold in
your hand
and then you say that single lump is
going to evolve to another whole
universe
that process of evolution is not a
single thread
that that process can branch because the
whole universe
if you did two updatings in different
orders for example
you would get different outcomes you
would get different whole universes
and that's very similar to the many
worlds story and one difference is
that in our models we're really you know
taking
seriously this idea that there's that
there's branching as a result of these
different possible orders of updating
and so on
and that there's this thing we call it a
multi-way graph
which is just this this description of
all these different possible parts of
history
but for us it's very important that the
parts of history can branch
and they can also merge and they merge
when two uh two outcomes for the
universe
end up you apply two different rules and
it so happens that they end up with an
identical universe
they end up with a hypograph that is
isomorphic that you can rearrange to be
exactly the same hypograph and so that
branching and merging process
is really important because one feature
of
many of our models and and in fact it
seems to it in the end it's a ubiquitous
feature of all of them
but that's not how it initially looks
initially it looks like you have to pick
it specially but in the end you don't
is this thing we call causal invariance
and so essentially what causal invariant
says is
every time there's a branch there will
be a subsequent merge
so in other words even though you
thought you were going to go in two
different branches of history
even though for a while you've got two
completely incompatible structures of
space time
in the end they will merge in the end
they'll be
and that's some and so that's why
in our models that's in the end why you
get object objectivity in quantum
mechanics
well let me see so what happens if i'm
just a conventional many worlds person
um there's perfectly deterministic
evolution of the entire wave function it
will branch
and part of the reason why it branches
and
operationally they never merge
is because there's some environment
which is huge numbers of degrees of
freedom
and the different states in the
environment will never exactly
line up so eventually you might imagine
them emer
you know merging back together 10 to the
100 years from now is
that the kind of thing you have going on
or is your re-emerging much
more rapid no the re-merging is faster
than that
but again it's a little complicated but
the
the fact that there is divergence and
merging is basically
so what what in the end happens is that
the uncertainty principle
is a story of essentially curvature in
this
uh in this basically multi-way graph
space
and it's just like in in space time one
of the sort of
you know the classic feature is you go
around a square
does it does it you know you you go
around a square with all the right
angles and distances does it close up
if space is curved it doesn't close up
and what's happening in our models is
it's the exact same thing although the
space is more complicated and more like
a hilbert space
um that uh what's happening is the same
exact kind of thing
is what leads to the uncertainty
principle in quantum mechanics
it's that same failure to to close up
and now what ends up being the case and
we don't
understand this as completely as i would
like yet
um so so just to give some sense of the
the sort of the the situation
with respect to you know what we know
and what we don't know so these
multi-way graphs
uh okay so first thing to say about
multi-way graphs is
they represent the sort of branching and
merging
of parts of history for the universe so
what you one thing you can do is you can
say at any given time
what is the structure of all of those
possible branches of history
so just like in in space time we're
going to say let's pick a space like
hypersurface let's pick a
simultaneous moment for all these
different parts of space
what does space look like well we can do
the same kind of thing for this
multi-way graph
if we do that we get this thing which
has all these different
all these different sort of possible
states of the universe
and how are they connected well they're
connected in what we call a branchial
graph
as a graph that represents these
different branches and so
one convenient way to construct a
branchial graph is to look at the common
ancestry
of those states so if two of those
states
just branched one step before they're
close together in the branch shell graph
if they branch many many many steps
before they're further apart
and so you can you can construct just
like from this
sort of uh structure of space time you
can construct a sort of instantaneous
structure of space
so from this multi-way graph you can
construct what we call branchial space
this is the instantaneous representation
of the possible
branches of quantum history and in a
sense it's a map of entanglements
because every one of these branchings
that the fact that they had a common
ancestor
and that they will is is a story of
entanglement
that's saying that these two branches of
history are not independent
they are connected by the fact that they
are entangled
so in a sense this branchial space is a
map of quantum entanglements
and so it's really i think incredibly
cool
because braunshield space has many of
the same attributes the physical space
has
it's more like a hilbert space it's a
little bit complicated and we don't
fully understand it yet
it's something like a what is the analog
in space time we have this idea of
minkowski space which has both
sort of the the usual euclidean type
space for space
and then this notion of time being a
separate thing and
exactly how that works for hilbert space
the analog of minkowski space for the
hilbert space of states we don't
understand it may be something related
to twister space
that's a special case of it but it's
something we don't yet understand
but one thing we do know is um you know
in terms of what we understand what we
don't understand
we do know that our multi-way graphs
reproduce a an approach to quantum
mechanics called categorical quantum
mechanics
and um we can just show that they are
equivalent basically
and it's known that categorical quantum
mechanics is equivalent to standard
standard quantum mechanics that people
studied from the 1920s and so on
and not only can we show that they're
equivalent one of the recent things in
the last month or two
has been we can actually use our models
to model quantum circuits
and we can essentially compile a
standard quantum circuit into a
multi-way graph
and the big excitement of the last few
weeks has been
and we can do better circuit
optimization
in multi-way graphs than you've been
able to do in standard quantum circuit
formalism so in other words we can
we can if you want to simulate a quantum
circuit
it's better to do it through our model
than it is to do it through the standard
mechanisms of quantum mechanics
but we know the answers have to be the
same so that's that's what we know for
quantum mechanics we don't yet know
fully how that works for quantum field
theory quantum mechanics
just for other people's benefit i know
you know this very well but
but you know quantum mechanics is a
story of you know what do individual
particles do
quantum field theory is a story of even
if you can make particles and the
particles are
sort of spread out through space how
does that work quantum mechanically
and that's a more difficult thing which
we're just starting to understand
i do want to dig in i want to dig in
more specifically to the different
to mapping your approach onto the
different interpretations of quantum
mechanics but
but let me let's just uh give
back up a little bit and keep it simple
for the folks who are trying to stay
with us here
if i look at the pictures of the graphs
of the hyper graphs that are following
the rules
um very naively it looks super duper
classical
there's a graph something is happening
at every point so could you just explain
why you know you even get something like
the double slit experiment where you can
get interference
but then if you look at it you don't get
interference is that something that pops
out of
your model yes yes um i mean
by pop out there's a little bit of
there's a little bit of effort to make
that pop
shorter of course but um um the okay
so when you see pictures of these hyper
graphs
they are pictures drawn for a particular
branch of history particular branch of
quantum mechanical history
okay that's what we're easily able to
visualize now it's been a big project
to make what we call local multi-way
systems which mix
spatial extent with branchial extent
that is mix things which are moving
around in space
with things which are going to different
branches of history and we've been this
has been a
a big challenge because it's pretty hard
for us humans to visualize that stuff
and we've been we've been working on it
for the last year actually we're getting
fairly close to having pretty good
visualizations of that but those are
those are significantly more difficult
to understand
but the the typical pictures you'll see
our our project is full of graphs so
there's many different kinds of graphs
that show up and they're they're kind of
in all the one of the things that's been
a big
kind of practical win is that we at some
moment we kind of did the colors for our
model
and you know picked this graph is going
to be this color good this graph is
going to be this other color
and so as soon as you see one of these
things you can tell that's a causal
graph that's a branch of graph or
whatever
um that's just a uh and um you know
because all the
all the code for our models is all
openly available
people have been just using that code
and so people have been following kind
of the
the color standards which really help
but so there are there are
probably six different kinds of graphs
that show up
the ones that are the most common and
colored bullish
okay are uh the ones that are the the
hypographs that represent the
instantaneous structure of space
so there are then these multi-way graphs
that represent
the um uh the kind of the the um the
branching and merging of quantum
histories
then there are branchial grafts which
are traditionally pink
in our world um that represent these
slices
through the multi-way system they
represent so
in in space time you're taking a slice
through space
time and and finding this is what space
instantaneously looks like
in the multi-way graph you take a slice
and you're saying
this is what the instantaneous map of
quantum states looks like
and in fact what happens is in in
relativity
we're used to having this idea of
reference frames of how do we label
what space and time are how does an
observer decide what counts of space
what counts as time and so on
if the observer is going at different
speeds you know you're tipping the
reference frame all those kinds of
things
we have exactly the same kind of thing
in quantum mechanics we have what we
call quantum observation frames
which are basically the the the thing
that represents
this corresponds to a a particular state
of the quantum world
and you can think of these in branchial
space
you can think of these points in
branchial space which are histories of
the universe
as being uh different quantum
eigenstates
so you you can think of them as being
different uh
basis elements so different different
things from which you would make up a
quantum state
and so then what happens is when you
have one of these quantum observation
frames you've sliced
the this multi-way graph you've got this
whole collection of quantum states
and now you ask in for example so
so now okay this is a one other thing i
have to explain
in quantum mechanics the sort of the big
idea
you know is this notion of quantum
amplitudes that is
you just get to know there's this this
object which is a you know has complex
numbers
you know associated with it and all this
kind of thing that is the quantum
amplitude
and so the question is that that quantum
amplitude
the the the complex numbers that are
associated with it
you know one of the things that we've
realized is the idea that you can think
of a quantum amplitude in terms of
complex numbers is confusing
in fact the right way to think about it
is it has a magnitude and it has a phase
and in our models the magnitude of the
quantum amplitude
is the result of path counting in the
multi-way graph so in other words
if there are many ways to get to that
state
in the multi-way graph the magnitude of
the quantum amplitude
is determined by the number of ways to
get to that that point in the multi-way
graph
the phase of the quantum amplitude is
determined by the position in branchial
space
so in other words the idea is as you
move around in branchial space
you are changing the the phase the
coordinates of branchial space
are essentially phase coordinates in
quantum mechanics sorry you
might need to tell me what branchial
space is again okay
so so okay so that then we've got
this all possible histories of the
universe which correspond to this
multi-way graph they branch they merge
it's a complicated thing now we're
saying let's
let's and and that graph is being formed
through time
so ever every and so now we say let's
take
an instantaneous time slice across that
graph
it is the quantum analog of a reference
frame in relativity
okay and that and by the way those
reference frames can get quite
wild in quantum mechanics they're
somewhat wilder than the ones you would
typically use in general activity
at least that's that's our view of how
this works
so so those reference frames are sort of
the choice of the observer
they're not they're not something that
is intrinsic to the physics
they're just oh we've got this multi-way
graph now we're going to say
for our purposes we're going to say this
is what the time slices of that will be
like
okay so that what this branchial graph
is the structure you get by slicing
through this multi-way graph so you're
asking
the various points in this multiple
graph how are they arranged
well we can say they're arranged nearby
if they
correspond to something which just had a
common ancestor just one step back they
had a common ancestor and other ones
you know you have to so basically what
happens is the simplest way to make
these branchial graphs
is you simply join by an edge every pair
of nodes that have a common ancestor
okay and then so what that means is if
there are
if there are things are far apart in the
bar show graph it means
their common ancestor was probably many
steps from the past
and and the idea then is that that
okay so the claim which is again
mathematically quite non-trivial
is that the coordination of branchial
space
that is if you're trying to assign
coordinates just like in in physical
space you'd say
they're all these atoms of space and
they're just connected in certain ways
but now we say
based on those connections it is we can
say this one has coordinate position
blah blah blah
and it's next to this other one which
has a very similar coordinate position
okay so the same you can do the same
kind of thing in branch of space you can
try and coordinate
is bronchial space and the claim is the
coordinates of branchial space are the
phase of the quantum amplitude
so in other words what that means so so
just to
sort of perhaps for people's benefit
maybe we can um
explain something about so you know
i don't know how how to we can try doing
let's see you probably can do this
better than i can but but explain in
quantum phase
but but you know well yeah sorry the way
that i just say it is that you know
the the wave function for a single
particle
is like a wave sometimes it's positive
sometimes it's negative or plus or minus
i
so different contributions can
destructively interfere as well as
constructively interfere
right but the the critical idea in a
sense is as you have that wave that's
going up and down
the phase of the wave is at a particular
moment in time
are you up or are you down right and the
phase is kind of the shifting of that
wave
relative to a particular moment in time
so what we're saying is
the these the the um this
branchial space represents kind of
where the where that thing is shifted
the the position in bronchial space
corresponds to a certain shift
of that of that thing so so here's the
place where
where it's actually my favorite result
so far in our physics project okay
so um which is worth explaining because
then we can talk about double star
experiment a little bit more easily
okay so let's talk about physical space
one of the questions is if you are if
you have
an object a particle for example in
physical space
how will it move in physical space and
the standard
idea of general relativity is and of
actually newtonian physics
is it moves you know according to a
shortest path
from one from one point to another so
it's like whatever the shortest path is
in space
it'll go along that shortest path if the
base is flat the shortest path will be a
straight line
if space is curved the shortest path
might be deformed
and the big idea of you know in
einstein's equations and so on is
the deformation of space the curvature
of space is produced by the presence of
energy momentum by the presence of mass
in space so essentially what we're
saying is jd6
in space are deflected by the presence
of energy gd6 shortest paths in space
are deflected by the presence of energy
that's kind of a version of what's
happening in general relativity
okay so now let's look at these
multi-way graphs
so the the derivation of the einstein
equations
and the uh deflection of gd6
by the presence of energy is something
we can do on
in in terms of our you know rewriting of
hypergraphs and
a bunch of mathematics associated with
that so it's sort of a mathematical
result from that
now something very analogous to that
mathematical result is also true for the
multi-way graph
and what then happens is the geod6
essentially in branchial space the
shortest paths in this bronchial space
are also deflected by the presence of
energy momentum
okay so this is where it gets it's
really fun because
the the the sort of the you know the
sort of a good core formulation of
quantum mechanics is the prime and path
integral
and the feminine path integral says you
look at all these possible paths of
history
and you say the phase the quantum phase
associated with the path of history
is you know e to the i s over h bar
where
s is this quantity the so-called the
action
which is a an integral of lagrangian
density
which is essentially the aversion of the
amount of energy momentum in a
particular region
of something now in our world that
that's
a particular region of branch hill space
effectively the density of energy
momentum
in branchial space leads to the
deflection of jd6 in branchial space
and so what does that mean if the if the
position in branchial space is the phase
of the quantum amplitude
that means the deflection of a jd sick
is a change of phase
and the feminine path integral is
precisely telling you
that the presence of energy momentum
leads to a change of phase in a quantum
amplitude
so what it's saying is the sort of the
the bigger picture here is
that the the same mathematics that leads
to the einstein equations
in space-time leads to the feminine path
integral
in in multi-way graphs and bronchial
space and so on so in a sense
these two sort of fundamental principles
of of 20th century physics
general relativity and quantum mechanics
in our models
are basically the same thing except that
the uh general relativity is a story of
what happens in space time
and uh the um and quantum mechanics is
the story of what happens in what we
sometimes call branch time
the thing you get which is the sort of
cross of branchial space
uh together with time so this might be
this might be a very unfair question but
i think there's a there's something
super simple that i am
missing here which is i i just don't see
where the negative numbers come in i
i hear you saying that uh there's this
position in branchial space is a phase
and i get that if that is true
you get the result you want to have but
why are there a little bit more
complicated
just the simplest possible explanation
for the negative
numbers would make me happy in other
words the reason why you can
interfere as well as uh add your
probability let me explain yeah i'll
explain so
so let's say you're doing a double slot
experiment
okay the photon can go through one slit
it can go through the other slit
those two possibilities the question is
where do those different possible parts
of the photon where are they in
branchial space
in physical space they're going through
two slits the question is where are they
in branchial space
if those two possibilities wind up
at essentially the same point in branch
hill space
that is that they end up with the same
phase
if those two things wind up at opposite
ends of bronchial space
those two possible parts of the photon
end up
in two radically different pieces of
branchial space okay so what
so the issue is how does an observer
observe what's going on so this is again
i'm afraid there's another level of
concept we have to have here
which is how an observer um makes sense
of what's going on in the quantum
universe
sure so the one of the issues is
when you are an observer embedded within
the universe
you well we can talk about space time
and and causal
and the let's forget space time for a
second in this
in this world of multi-way graphs and
branching and merging and so on
one of the things that's a little bit
brain twisting is you as an observer
are also branching you're part of this
multi-way graph
so the question of quantum mechanics is
how does a branching brain
perceive a branching universe so in
other words
your brain is branching just like the
universe is branching okay and so now
what you have to do and this is where
for example
the idea of a single thread of
experience a single thread of time is
important
because the whole notion of us as
observers is
we have at least the fiction that our
brain doesn't branch
we have the fiction that definite things
happen
and so the question is how do we
implement that fiction
and then is the is our implementation of
the fiction
consistent with what we actually observe
in the world okay so the way that we
a convenient way and this is a an idea
of jonathan gorod who's one of the
people who's been working on this
project
is um uh the the what he calls the
completion interpretation of quantum
mechanics okay
and what it has to do with is
imagine we've got a branch but then say
but the observer has to corral those
branches together
in order to believe that something
definite happens
so how is the observer going to do that
what the observer does
is to just say i'm going to imagine that
these two branches are equivalent i'm
just going to make a mathematical
equivalence between them
and then i'm going to see what
consequence does that have for my view
of the universe
okay and and so that's the thing so
it might be the case that the view of
the universe knitting together these
branches
would rapidly become incredibly
inconsistent
but this causal invariance property
implies that eventually
these branches will merge so eventually
it's going to be okay
but the question of whether the observer
can kind of speed that up
and say no i'm going to insist it's okay
right now
even though it might take a century for
these branches from different parts of
the universe to merge
it's okay to think of them as merging
right now so that's a
that's a consequence mathematically of
this causal variance idea that it's
possible to do that
but so in that interpretation what
you're doing is you're essentially
making
completions that try and corral back
together
these different branches of history okay
so what happens
if the two photons wind up at opposite
ends of branchial space
basically what happens is you as an
observer
have to construct completions that
basically complete the whole universe
because you're trying to get from one
end of branchial space to another you're
trying to knit everything together
and that means basically that photon as
far as you're concerned isn't there
because and so that's so essentially the
reason that you're getting
you know destructive interference is
that you as an observer
simply can't knit it together to say
there really is a photon
here it's like the photon has been just
smashed
into into pieces that are scattered all
over branch hill space
you know what you could say i actually
did understand that i believe
even though i wasn't necessarily
expecting to but uh it seems and maybe
this is
again an unfair comment but i'll let you
riff on it
it seems like just like we thought we
needed interpretations of quantum
mechanics in the 1930s that somehow we
need interpretations of
hypergraphs or growing hypergraphs i
mean
the the story you just told which i'm
perfectly willing to grant gets you
the double slit etc does seem to involve
some metaphysical interpretational steps
along the way
fair point i mean this is this is why
this is a fundamental point
in in our models if we were not
roughly the way we are we would not
conclude that the laws of physics are
the way they are
so consider the case of the gas
molecules again
if we were one of these little demons
that's able to compute everything about
the gas molecules and
do all those things we wouldn't conclude
that
thermodynamics and hydrodynamics work
the way they do
that's right we would say oh actually we
noticed that these little correlations
of of molecules here and there on the
other
and we'd get a completely different
conclusion so the fact that we
derive quantum mechanics is a
consequence of the fact that we
are roughly the way we are not in detail
with two eyes and you know all this kind
of thing but
but in you know so and in particular
the fact that the branching brain
perceiving the branching universe
has the idea that definite things happen
that's critical
if we didn't have that notion and you
can think about it in terms of how our
brains work
you know we got all these neurons firing
all over our brains and
in a sense there wouldn't be any real
reason to think that there will be a
definite thread of experience
that we have it could just be you know
there's all these different things
happening
all throughout our brain and it's you
know this is a
this is a fundamental feature of our
experience of the world is that we
believe there's a definite threat of
time
and so yes that is necessary and you
know i think without that
and it's interesting to to think about
it you know what do the aliens so to
speak think physics is like
because you know for example it it
matters
probably that we are roughly the size we
are it matters that we have this notion
of single thread of time
um you know i i don't think we would
recognize the aliens so to speak
if they didn't have something like a
single threat of time it doesn't just
doesn't
you know i'm i'm fond of making the
comment you know the weather has a mind
of its own
you know it's got all this complicated
hydrodynamic processes happening in the
atmosphere and so on but yet
we don't have the idea that it has some
sort of you know human-like
consciousness
usually at least depending on our
animism our level of animism
yeah but so but would i be then correct
to conclude from that
that you think that from this kind of
fundamental setup with the hyper graphs
and the updates and so forth
we could not get a universe that was
fundamentally classical
and had you know uh observers like
ourselves in it
i think our models are very
fundamentally quantum mechanical okay i
think that you can't really get
you know what you can okay so
what you would have to do is say there
is only one okay here's a way you can
get something that's like
a classical universe and at first it
sounds completely crazy but
let's say the universe was built using a
turing machine
so a turing machine is this model of
computation that
has you know it's tape that has all this
data on it
and has this head that moves up and down
along the tape
and at any moment it's only doing one
thing
it's only at the position of the head
that anything changes
and so you could say imagine a universe
where the um where the turing machine
does a definite thing let me think about
this for a second
um yeah i i
let me think about this is that right
well okay so
you can certainly imagine setting it up
so that there is only one possible
thread of time
because the turing machine is an
ordinary turing machine and for every
state it gets into
it has only one possible successful
state um
and so you might say and so that would
be a kind of degeneration
of a model like ours that is classical
yeah okay that's fair but but usually
what's happening is there are many
different places where things can happen
so there are many choices of what can
happen
what what what you do now what you do
next
et cetera et cetera et cetera and you
know i keep on
i'm sort of dancing around one issue
which we haven't talked about which is
the
notion of causal relationships between
updating events
so we've got two different updating
events and
we could say which one happens before
which other one
well if one of them specifically if the
output from one of them is used as the
input to another one
then it better be the case the one whose
output is being used occurs before the
one
that needs that output as input right so
that defines a certain ordering
on certain events have a definite
ordering i mean in physics terms those
are the time like separated events
um the uh and those are events that are
necessarily time like
separated so then then there are other
events
that could happen you could decide
that you're going to say these two
events happen simultaneously the
the spacecraft landed on mars right
as i was eating lunch so to speak and
you know that was those were considered
in
simultaneous events so one of the issues
is
given this set of events that are
happening
there are certain causal relationships
that is one event
must occur before another event and you
can make another kind of graph
a so-called causal graph that represents
that net of relationships
and just to make things more complicated
in the multi-way graph there is a
multi-way causal graph
which says there are these events
happening and events can be separated
they can either be timelike that is one
event must occur before another event
they can be space-like in the sense that
they can be at different positions in
physical space
or they can also be branch-like in the
sense that they occur on different
branches of quantum history
and so all three of those things are
possible time-like space like
branch-like separation
and that's uh uh and in fact the
interplay between those things gets
pretty interesting when you start
talking about
you know things in black holes and adf
cft and all this kind of stuff
that's that's that's how those kinds of
things seem to come out
is the relationship between time like
space like branch-like separated events
i mean you've hinted at this a little
bit but uh maybe to concisely say how
you would characterize
the solution to the measurement problem
of quantum mechanics in your
view i mean there's a standard list of
options with many worlds and hidden
variables and dynamical collapses
are you different than all of those
probably
i mean you know i'm not sure because i i
think that
um uh let's see we have a much more
microscopic view
of what happens in measurement because
we're trying to describe the whole
universe
we don't get to say here's my quantum
system
and then outside of my quantum system is
my measurement system
everything has to be part of the
description that we're giving of the
universe
and so that's that's the first big big
difference
now i think um
if it depends what you mean by what the
quantum measurement problem is so one
one thing that i think is a a
significant piece of the quantum
measurement story
is why do people think that definite
things happen
and so what essentially is going on is
different quantum measurement different
quantum frames
cause people to believe at some moment
that different things have happened but
there's some sense in which there is a
global consistency
to what must happen so again
in other words so so the fact that there
are two different outcomes from this
measurement
is a consequence of the fact that the
observer
can have defined two different quantum
observation frames
and that is what causes those different
possible outcomes from the experiment
it sounds like in some sense you're
closest in spirit to many worlds in the
sense that
uh someone who believed in hidden
variables or dynamical collapses would
say that
there just is one outcome for every
measurement you don't need to think very
hard about it
right no that's correct i mean this this
does not have that idea this this has
the idea
that the outcome is in a sense based on
the the frame in which with which the
observer observes it so in a sense it's
kind of like a many worlds thing where
you know which branch did you go on but
the the difference is
in a sense that in our situation those
branches
always eventually merge so in other
words even though
you've picked a particular this observer
at this moment has got this outcome
that there will be eventual consistency
in how the universe behaves right
now you know have we figured all of this
out not completely
let me give you an example of where sort
of the frontier of what we understand
and don't understand
so an obvious question is what does it
mean for quantum computing
so in quantum computing there's kind of
this notion that has been around
since since i first studied this stuff
around 1981 or so
that gosh in quantum mechanics there's
this you know
all these different possible paths of
history and i happened to study this
with dick fineman so he was very into
the multiple parts of history idea
because that had been his
his idea for a way of setting up
quantity it does make sense it's like
just think you know if you could get
this this computation to not just go in
one
not just do one computation at a time
but follow all these different possible
paths of computation
you could in parallel work out all these
different different results
and you'd be able to you know factor in
just fast we didn't know about that at
that time
but um those kinds of things the so
so the idea of quantum computing you
know that the big hope is
just use all those parts of history to
do a different computation on each path
but the you know the next question is
in the end we have to observe what the
answer was
and so in a sense we've got all these
threads of history that have all split
apart
they're all doing their different things
we've got to corral all those threads of
history back together again
to make a definite measurement and say
what happened
and so in our models we can actually ask
what is microscopically involved in
corralling those
those threads of history back together
and so
in jonathan's setup of this completion
interpretation
we have at least a model of that which
is it involves these
these completions these places where you
assume that two branches are connected
and by the way the mathematical
underpinning of that somewhat
interesting
the the mathematical underpinning comes
from the theory of automated theorem
proving
which is might seem irrelevant but it
isn't
and um so the point is when you have in
mathematics
you say there's some axiom system you
say you know x
plus y is always equal to y plus x you
know x plus 0 is equal to 0
is equal to x and so on and then you say
given those rules uh
is it you know can you prove that
x i don't know x you know some some
results in algebra can you
can you prove that results by by just
and you say can i
and one way to think about that is can i
get from one algebraic expression
to another algebraic expression just by
making this series of moves that
correspond to
applying particular axioms so then if
you say well i'm starting off from one
expression
now let me apply those axioms in all
possible ways
and build up this whole graph of
possible outcomes
well what you build is precisely one of
these multi-way graphs
and that the the space of possible
results that you can get
starting from one expression what can
you get as a multi-way graph and so
automated theorem proving is the
question of
the proof of a theorem is a path that
goes from one expression to another
expression
so automated theorem proving is about
finding that path and so
completions become the formation of
lemmas
so in mathematics you would say let's
make a lemma that where we assume
where we where we prove that this
particular thing is equal to this thing
and that's a piece that we'll use in our
big proof and so these completions are
essentially lemmas
they are their assumptions about how the
universe works
that we're that we as observers are
making and so one thing we can then ask
for the quantum computing case
is how many such lemmas do we have to
produce
do we how much effort of knitting
together the structure of branchial
space do we
observers have to do in order to
conclude the result of the quantum
computation and it seems
we're still nailing this down it's still
a little bit messy
but it seems that you can never win with
quantum computing
that is that when you branch out in all
these different ways
the effort to corral things back
together is at least as great
as the gain that you get from things
branching apart
now you know to to really nail that down
we have to get
ever better models of the observer and
that's just not something that
traditional
models of quantum mechanics traditional
interpretations of quantum mechanics
they are out of that business because
they just say and the observer works
like this
external to the quantum system but we
have to be more microscopic
and say no we're actually going to
describe how the observer is working
and so our best model so far is
jonathan's completion interpretation
that um uh that involves these
essentially lemmas being produced
i'm sorry there's there's a traditional
understanding in uh
well there's an understanding in
traditional quantum computing that there
are
some problems for which quantum
mechanics certainly gives you a speed up
uh are you saying that's not true in
your model yeah i think
i think it's not going to be true that's
my guess i think what's going to happen
is
you know if you take like shaw's
algorithm for factoring right which is
primarily a quantum fourier transform
that you know that fourier transform is
done beautifully quickly
because they're all these threads that
are running in parallel the problem is
every thread is somewhere in a different
place in branchial space
that thread but us observers we have to
corral all those things back together
again
in order to tell what actually happened
and that's you know so there's a
you know usually in quantum computing
one just says and then there's a
measurement
now in in actuality when you have an
actual device
you have all kinds of issues in making
that measurement all kinds of how
quickly does it decohere
all these kinds of things there are all
these kinds of very practical
experimental
uh you know features and i think people
have generally said
given the formalism of quantum mechanics
it
you know it's like well all this quantum
stuff happens and then boom we do a
measurement
and the boom we do a measurement is
actually pretty difficult in practice
with actual experiments
but people have said but you know if we
do these experiments well enough
it'll become the mathematical
idealization that you know von neumann
and others
made about how measurement works and i
don't think that's going to be true
i mean we're not sure yet but um it
seems likely
that there will be no way to do to sort
of
that if you're honest about how the
measurement works
the measurement takes effort but are you
saying that that's going to be a generic
result about even conventional quantum
mechanics or
is this specific to your approach
um if you could if you could study how
measurement works well enough in quantum
mechanics
yes the problem is in in traditional
quantum mechanics
it's like this is all the quantum these
are all the quantum amplitudes and the
hammer comes down
and it's you know the born rule or
whatever and that's the end of it
um and and so you don't you don't get to
look inside that measurement process
and when people you know i'm i'm
probably not you know one of the strange
things that's happened to me in this
physics project is that
you know i i knew about everything that
was going on in physics not everything
perhaps but
a lot of things 40 years ago and then i
kind of went to sleep for 40 years and
woke up again
and it's remarkable it's really cool
actually to see
you know a lot of stuff really didn't
change and some stuff
advanced and it's like you know i used
to know the masses of all these
elementary particles you know
the mass of the lander is 1115 mev
and now i look it up again it's you know
1114.962 or something
it's like that's um uh so you know there
are things like that and they're also
also mathematical ideas and so on but
i'm not sure that i would know
uh everything that people have done in
kind of um uh
sort of models of quantum measurement
but certainly back when i last knew
about it
in in great detail uh people were sort
of starting to say
and then we take the small number of
quantum degrees of freedom that we're
looking at as the quantum system
and we let that sort of spread out in a
larger number of quantum degrees of
freedom
where eventually it will become
unambiguous what happened
for essentially thermodynamic reasons
yeah because it's it's more or less like
you know what happens in the gas getting
randomized and in fact this was a thing
dick fineman and i worked on
back when we were we were both
consultants for a computer company in
boston
and we were i was insisting that we
tried to do something useful and we
tried to invent a quantum randomness
chip
and so we tried to think about how would
you make you know
in those days one gigahertz seemed like
an impossibly fast
clock rate for this chip you know how
would you make quantum randomness at one
gigahertz
and what we realized is you know you
have this little quantum effect
but then when you measure that effect
you have to amplify it
into a sort of classical number of
degrees of freedom and that process
in order for you to have an unambiguous
result in order for successive
bits that you measure to be uncorrelated
you have to essentially have
essentially sort of a thermodynamic
phenomenon going on you have to be
you know it has to randomize then that
that randomization has to not be
correlated with the next thing that
happens
and that was the that was to me the
first sort of sign
that there was going to be a cost to
measurement so to speak
well if you if you start a podcast of
your own you can have me on and we can
talk about interpretations of quantum
mechanics and that would be fun but
okay you can teach me all about it but i
mean
i think that that that does help me
understand a little bit because what
you're what you're
saying is that it's possible that your
approach
has a different attitude toward let's
just say the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics so the next obvious
question is
do you have a different attitude toward
the schrodinger equation towards the
unitary evolution i mean the
conventional schrodinger equation is
continuous in time and you're not
continuous in time
are you getting the schrodinger equation
as an approximation
or is there some sense in which it's
exact yeah right so
so it's very similar and we don't know
all the details of this yet
but let's talk about the space-time case
in the space-time case we've got these
atoms of space and with connections and
so on
and we're looking at things on a large
scale and what should happen
is that just like in a fluid where the
molecules are bouncing around but on a
large scale we get the fluid equations
on a large scale we should get the
einstein equations and that's what
theoretically
uh theoretically we should get now when
i say theoretically
this is you know when physicists do
mathematics
they're really sloppy and you know there
are many degrees by the way
you know it's the these these there's a
certain amount of computational
irreducibility which leads to a certain
amount
of randomness which leads to certain
statistical averages working out in a
certain way
when you look at the you know the
distances have to be large compared to
the
elementary distance between atoms of
space and small compared to the size of
the universe and the curvature has to be
small blah blah blah blah blah
a whole bunch of conditions but with all
of those conditions
in physicist level mathematics we can
derive einstein's equations
now it's worth pointing out that the
effort to derive the fluid equations
from molecular dynamics
has been unsuccessful for a hundred
years that is
with with a level of you know we can
derive einstein's equations
with the same level of kind of
mathematical rigor that you can derive
the fluid equations
which is to say it isn't really
mathematically rigorous but if you take
all kinds of limits
that that one advantage that we have
actually one big advantage that i always
forget
is that we've done endless simulations
so we actually know what limits work and
what don't
right so it's not like it's just let's
hope this works based on you know some
mathematical
uh sort of hope it's it's like we we ran
an experiment with a billion cases
and this is what happened so we can kind
of check those assumptions but but okay
so
so what then happens is what we are
saying is
that the from this kind of microscopic
atoms of space thing
when we do that when we look at that on
a large scale we
reproduce einstein's equations so one of
the things that we've been doing
recently
jonathan has been much involved in this
has been
saying well what about practical
numerical relativity
so people study you know black hole
mergers and they do that by taking
you know the the structure of the black
holes and they say we have einstein's
equations which are partial differential
equations
and then we will but in order to make
those work on a computer
we have to discretize them because the
computer deals digitally with with
sort of digital elements and um
so then you make numerical relativity
where you've made some kind of mesh
that represents some approximation to
space time
as you know approximating the space time
of einstein's equations
so that's kind of the traditional
approach now what we're doing instead is
to work upwards from the atoms so to
speak
so we're saying instead of going down
from the einstein equations
just come up from this kind of structure
of this
this hypograph and and um look at
uh you know what is the aggregate
behavior of all these atoms of space
the neat thing is that it actually works
and it's a practical method for doing
numerical relativity
so and in fact it's looking really
promising
to um uh as a and what's interesting so
this is now general relativity just a
a side comment for general relativity so
one thing you can ask is
so obviously in our simulations
the we have these atoms of space and we
simulate on our computer
i think the extreme kind of amusing
version is jonathan
has been doing all these simulations on
his laptop just to prove that that's
possible
which i think is totally crazy yeah but
so he has these simulations of black
hole mergers and things
done on his laptop um using our models
you could do a lot better if you weren't
just using a laptop
but anyway the the um uh the thing
that is a so it's not obvious that we
would be able to get
enough approximation to continuum space
just
kind of on a laptop from our atoms of
space rather than having to go
you know many many many orders of
magnitude but it
seems that that works so the next
question is in physical space
where might we see evidence of
discreteness in space-time
so in other words the the in other words
is there a way of making essentially a
gravitational microscope
that will see into the structure of
space time
and so one of the things we've looked at
is rapidly rotating black holes
right close to the critical you know
close to j equals m
um what happens and it's pretty neat
because in these
in these simulations that jonathan has
what you see is the thing
eventually as you go above the critical
angular momentum
critical spin rate for the black hole a
piece of space
simply separates so okay another thing
to explain is
in our models of physics this network
doesn't have a built-in notion of
dimension so
you know our experience is space is
three-dimensional but this network
doesn't have any particular number of
dimensions that are built into it
it can be the case that on a large scale
it approximates three-dimensional space
but because it doesn't have a fixed
number of dimensions
because it isn't microscopically a
manifold so to speak
it can do things like it can change its
topology things can there can be tears
that form in it
there can be holes that form in it and
so on and or more extremely there can be
pieces of the universe that just break
off
and so what we see happening at for
critical
supercritical black holes is a piece of
the universe just breaks off
and as um as it at the critical
uh angular momentum what you see is that
a piece of the universe is hanging by a
thread
and so there are these small number of
causal edges that essentially connect
one part of the universe to others
and so it's conceivable that we may get
some kind of
signature maybe in gravitational
radiation of
that discreteness you know in physics
terms probably shot noise
associated with the fact that there is a
that there are a small number of causal
edges
that are associated with that with that
situation so anyway that that's
but that's just the general relativity
case in the quantum mechanics case
they're asking about the schrodinger
equation so the schrodinger equation has
to emerge
as a pile of limits okay from the things
that we're doing
because the schrodinger equation is a
non-relativistic limit of uh
et cetera et cetera so the answer is i i
think
i mean well i'm sorry just to be just to
be super clear i'm using the
generalized version of the schrodinger
equation that would be just as true for
quantum field theory and relativity and
everything just h psi
equals i d by dt psi unitary evolution
of
a function right so so we are from the
setup of these multi-way graphs from the
interpretation of quantum amplitudes
we are guaranteed unit unitary evolution
100
not as an approximation that that you
think about that for a second
it's a little tricky because you have to
define what the initial and final states
are
and if you if you say i have the whole
multi-way graph
of everything i think you're guaranteed
it but if you say
if you say i'm going to make an i'm
going to look at a particular region of
space time
i think it's not so obvious i think
there is sure
that that's that's just true and even in
the regular schrodinger equation so that
um yeah
perfectly no i think that i i think let
me think about that for a second i
think that
let me see i mean quantum measurement is
not unitary that's a that's a thing that
we
that we have to deal with but a many
worlds person says that's just because
you're only seeing
part of the wave function in exactly the
same way that you are
right right but i i'm a little concerned
about the statement that the um
uh see the the
statement about the way the hamiltonian
appears there
in the in the non-relativistic stronger
equation is certainly not what we're
seeing
so because we have a you know our thing
is sort of relativistic from the get-go
um and so what i think let me think
about this for a second well you could
define it in terms of the path integral
i mean it's any unitary evolution from
one
one wave function to another one quantum
state to another but between
an initial hypersurface and a final
hypersurface
i think you inevitably get unitary
evolution but you have to define what
those hypersurfaces are
as you do in you know as as you do when
you merge relativity and quantum
general relativity in quantum mechanics
so i i think it's i'm
i'm uh i think that's right
i i would have to um i mean the
the part of this
yeah i think that that has to be that
way okay i mean the part that we've been
interested in recently
is can we make a practical scheme for
doing quantum field theory
in the same way that we can make a
practical scheme for dealing with
einstein's equations
and so in a sense you know one of the
things that
or encourages me in this project is what
i might call proof by compilation
that is the fact you know you say do you
really get einstein's equations
well we can do numerical relativity and
it actually works and we can do you know
black hole mergers and things
so if einstein's equations are right
then you know what we're doing is the
same
and um uh in quantum mechanics we've
been able to do this compilation of
quantum circuits
the next big challenge is to do quantum
field theory and to do
uh and to be able to do things like few
particle quantum mechanics
and uh you know those kinds of things
you know
for example let me give you an example
of how things get a little bit
complicated so in quantum mechanics
you know a very traditional thing is the
harmonic oscillator
just kind of the analog of you know
things bouncing on a spring back and
forth
in order to get that in our models you
have to have closed time-like curves
so in other words to get a perfect
harmonic oscillator
okay it's very easy to have a perfect
harmonic oscillator if you have closed
time-like curves
in other words if the if the history of
the universe recapitulate
if the history of the universe repeats
itself that's kind of how you get
something like a harmonic oscillator
that's how you get the idealization of a
harmonic oscillator now
in the real situation in physics we
probably don't believe that there are
perfect harmonic oscillators
we can decompose quantum fields into you
know as
in as let's think of it as a sum of
forming oscillators
but we're not imagining there's a
perfect harmonic oscillator here right
but if you say you might say and this is
relates to the kind of reverse
engineering versus building from the
ground up so to speak
you might say gosh how can you think you
have a model of quantum mechanics if you
can't even have
the harmonic oscillator but well we can
have a long oscillator but it's a weird
idealization which in our models shows
up with
with closed time like curves um and so
that's
you know that's an example of how things
get a little you know if you insist on
these idealizations
you end up sort of stressing as i think
you should
you kind of stress the model so it's
similar to you know if you said
you say i'm studying molecular dynamics
okay so then
somebody says well why can't you get
rigid body mechanics why can't you get
you know this thing with a solid object
that just moves around and doesn't
distort
well that's a complicated limit of
molecular dynamics
that involves you know atomic forces are
large compared to the
you know forces on the whole object blah
blah blah
you know it's it's um uh that's a
complicated story
and i think we're seeing some one of the
things that's difficult about our model
is that it attempts to be a model for
everything so you don't get
to say we're going to have them this
piece we're going to make a model for
that piece we're going to idealize away
you have to kind of everything has to
come together and that means that seeing
things like
how does the harmonic oscillator work
it's a weird idealization
yeah now that that does make sense if
you get exactly unitary evolution that
is to say you get something like the
schrodinger equation
um i mean a many worlds person will say
all there is is the schrodinger equation
you just need to pick the hamiltonian
and someone like me if i can indulge
myself you know our project is to start
from a
nothing but a hamiltonian expressed as a
list of energy eigenvalues and show how
there's an emergent
geometric structure that looks like a
graph you get einstein's equation and
the whole thing
it's similar in spirit in that sense to
what you're doing
but so then the question is if you
exactly get unitary evolution
what is the benefit to not just starting
with quantum mechanics in the
schrodinger equation versus starting
with hypergraphs
well because you have a whole structure
that you're building so i mean for
example when you say
what's the hamiltonian you know that
better come out of our model
so for example you could ask which we
haven't discussed what is energy in our
model
okay this is one of the things that
surprised me i thought energy was going
to be a very difficult to derive idea
that was going to require notions of
what particles are and so on and so on
and so on
it seems that energy is very simple it's
basically
the amount of activity in the hyper
graph and
a little bit more formally it's the flux
of causal edges through space like hyper
surfaces
and it's concerned it needs to be said i
mean so a causal edge
is is a is a causal connection between
two updating events
and so the question is if you have
a you have to say a little bit more
carefully because if you say it's the
density of activity
it's what the heck does density mean
when we don't have a notion of space yet
so the more formal thing is energy is
the flux of causal edges through space
like hypersurfaces
momentum is the flux of causal edges
through time-like liposurfaces
and um uh the um
actually you now make me wonder and i
don't think i know the answer to this
what is the flux of edges through
branch-like hyper surfaces i should know
the answer that and i don't immediately
know
and that's that's some that's related to
okay so so the point here is there's a
i think see one of the things that's
interesting in our models
is the relationship between quantum
energy and classical energy
because in our models it's the this
notion of in classical energy it's the
you know you've got this single thread
of history you've got this causal graph
associated with that thread of history
and you're asking this flux of calls
alleges but now you can also have this
multi-way chordal graph
which not only has space-like separation
of events
but also branch-like separation events
so events can be
separated in in in branches space and in
a physical space and then the idea is
that quantum energy is that activity
in uh in
this whole multi-way graph so it's the
amount of activity in the multi-way
causal graph
and so then like the lagrangian is this
relativistically invariant
that this is the you know lagrangian
density
is that uh that kind of uh you know
relativistically invariant notion of the
amount of activity
in this multi-way causal graph and so
for example one
one little mystery that this seems to
clear up
is the thing if you look at the planck
length you know the characteristic
length people often talk about for where
sort of quantum mechanics and gravity
have to kind of come together
in our models the elementary length is
much smaller than the planck length
and in the a typical thing is the planck
energy
well whereas the planck length is you
know 10 minus 34 meters or whatever it
is
the the planck uh the planck energy
is 10 to the 19 electron volts if i
remember correctly
what's that 10 to the 19 gev gev
okay thank you the um but it's about the
you know it's about the energy in a
thunderbolt or something a lightning
strike
it's huge not a very small quantum thing
um in our models the elementary energy
is also small because the elementary
energy
is an individual causal edge
in the multi-way causal graph and the
fact that what you observe
is is this thing the the analog of the
planck energy is something that has been
averaged that has been sort of summed
over all possible
branches in this multi-way causal graph
i mean
this is maybe this is a footnote forget
this this is just a
there's just a part of the story but but
so
you're you're saying why do we care
about this whole structure that we're
building
why not just put a hamiltonian in there
and what i'm saying is
the um uh for for listeners who don't
know this
hamiltonians and lagrangians are closely
related sure
they're they're sorry we didn't that i
think for you and me that's pretty
obvious
right yeah um that may not be obvious
but but in some sense you're like we
said there's a simple set of rules that
you start with
and i mean maybe maybe i can just jump
uh i'm gonna try to guess
what you're uh thinking here and then
you can tell me whether i'm right or
wrong
there's an infinite number of
hamiltonians i can write down but at
least for simple ones there's a finite
set of little rules that we can write
down for our hypergraphs so
maybe there's a map from the set of
rules to hamiltonians but it's a
very very you know one you know few too
few rather than covering the whole space
of possible hamiltonians
right well so this is a good question it
as you look at
simple you know rewrite rules for
hypergraphs you get some set of
hamiltonians
if you say oh i'm going to have a
million line program to represent my
rules for the hypergraph
then you're going to get some other you
know you can kind of custom engineer
whatever hamiltonian you want probably
got it okay so
it is not self-evident you know what
kind of hamiltonians
you get from simple update rules
we don't entirely know so for example it
looks like
we get ones that show local gauge
invariants
and then we have to ask you know and
that's a that's a
you know if you just pick your average
hamiltonian there's no particular reason
for it to have local gauge invariants
um but in our models it probably does
and so that's a good sign
now you know will we get you know what
other attributes would we like our
hamiltonians for the universe to have
well i mean you know my approach here is
to just say
let's see what we get and for example
okay so here's one of the complicated
things
so the hamiltonians that you will
typically write down in
in quantum field theory they are the
things that are in those hamiltonians
lagrangians whatever
are quantum fields they're quantum
fields that represent
uh you know
field operators that correspond to
particular particles
right so there'll be an electron quantum
field there'll be a photon quantum
field and so on now in our models we're
not yet talking about particles
so those hamiltonians have to be
what we have is a description of things
at a much lower level
than a place where you've got actual
field operators for particles
so for us that what are the particles
the particles are locally stable
kind of deformations in this in this
hypergraph
so for example an analogy in fluid
mechanics if you say what's
like a particle in fluid mechanics well
a vortex you know a kind of whirlpool
like thing
in a fluid that is locally stable and it
can move through the fluid and it can
track with other vortices
it's something vaguely similar to that
in our hypographs
uh more a kind of topological structure
um
that is some kind of not yet very well
understood
uh feature that is locally stable under
the rules
um and so when you talk about field
operators that would occur in
you know your average communal garden
particle physics lagrangian
those field operators are effective
descriptions of these deformations these
topological
these topologically stable objects in
this hypergraph
the hypergraph is a lower level
description and so
it takes you know it's not obvious and
it's a very good question
and we don't know you know how does
uh how does the thing that looks like it
operates in terms of particles how does
that emerge
you know what kind of things that look
like there in terms of particles
emerge from this lower level structure
because because in our models
you know all we have at the beginning is
the structure of space
particles are just features of the
structure of space
and they are you know so there's an
underlying dynamic i mean
one of the things that's sort of a
little shocking in our models
is that most of the activity of the
universe is
is associated with the maintenance of
the structure of space and has nothing
to do with all the particles that we
observe in space
so that that's a and so what what um
i mean so it's a it's a it's a very
reasonable question
how the hamiltonians that we're used to
in particle physics
emerge as effective hamiltonians from
this underlying dynamics
and we don't yet know the answer well
you know you i mean you mentioned the
particles
um as something that does come out as
these persistent structures
so but but as you certainly know
um quantum field theory the usual modern
physics way of saying things is that
fields are somehow more fundamental when
you perturb them and excite them
you get particle-like things there are
circumstances you know like the
condensation of the higgs field where
the particle language is not appropriate
is there
is there a view toward a more field-like
ontology coming out of this well i think
that
okay so again this is if if we say
when we talk about particles in particle
physics
they are as you say sort of you know
what we imagine is oh there's a particle
it's not interacting with anything it's
you know it's separated from everything
else
it has a definite momentum it is a
definite mode of the quantum field
and when it comes close to other
particles then you know it gets more
complicated and there are other modes of
the quantum field that get excited and
eventually some other particle goes out
and you observe it in a particle
detector but the
the um uh so for us
we have to think about what do those
scattering experiments look like what is
an experiment
where you have that separated particle
and this is one of the cases where
you know the we are building everything
from the ground up so we don't get to
say
oh it's just a separated particle in the
vacuum so to speak
it's a an excitation of some kind
embedded in the space that is that has a
lot of activity in it
so so for example when we talk about
you know so one of the things that i'm
wondering is will there be
bizarrely different kinds of stable
structures
in our hyper graph that aren't like the
particles we're used to
so in other words you know you mentioned
the higgs field the higgs field is a
case where we have this condensate where
we have a
sort of uniform value of the higgs field
throughout space
and that's you know that's a simple case
there are you know people know about you
know solitarn type
solution to field equations um and you
know there are
other kinds of things like that and one
of the possibilities is that in our
models
particularly because we have this
dimension variation that there might be
bizarrely different stable structures
that could exist in the context of our
models that don't
seem like particles of the ordinary
climate that momenta
and things like that might be something
bizarrely different maybe it's even
related to something
you know maybe it's related to dark
matter for all we know i mean it's just
something
that could exist as a as a sort of
stable feature of our universe that goes
beyond just the structure of space
but it has a form that we don't yet
don't yet understand
and i think i mean in um the the other
thing to realize so in standard particle
physics
we talk about virtual particles you know
you can they're always part these
particle anti-particle pairs that
that are sort of popping into existence
in the vacuum for a very short time and
then annihilating
so in and and one of the features of
that it's always been somewhat
mysterious in quantum field theory
because quantum field theory says
there's an infinite number of these
virtual particles that are occurring
all over the universe and that
corresponds to
effectively a very high energy density
of stuff in the universe
how can that be how can it not in
einstein's equation say you know
whenever you have energy
you're going to curl up the universe
with you know gravitational attraction
associated with that energy how can the
universe not curl up into a tiny ball
because of these vacuum fluctuations of
virtual particles
well in our models the those
the sort of limiting case of those
virtual particles
is these actual uh rewrite rules
in our uh in our hyper graph so in other
words
the this sort of the ultimate version of
all of those virtual particles
it's just all these little rewrite rules
in the hypergraph which in our models
are exactly what create the structure of
space
so in a sense that makes it a little
less mysterious
that you know all of this virtual
particle stuff
doesn't have this terrible effect this
terrible gravitational effect
on the universe now you can ask things
like you know
can you imagine how the higgs mechanism
works and all these kinds of things
and yes i've i've thought about that and
there's a there's a certain amount you
can say i don't think we
we can't um uh i mean i was very
disappointed when the higgs particle was
discovered i
i kind of knew it was going to happen
but it was it was um
uh it was kind of like like it's kind of
a hack and it's disappointing that um
you know it it looks so far the higgs
mechanism looks like a hack
and the question is can we make it look
less like a hack and that will be really
neat
so one little footnote is that uh you
might be interested in work by tom banks
and willie fishler who have emphasized
within the context of
more or less conventional quantum
gravity the point you just made about
the cosmological constant that
we should not think about it as the sum
of all these virtual fluctuations we
should think of it as an input
a boundary condition they call it that
just sets the size of space
in some sense so that's more in line i
think with the philosophy yeah right
that you think
i i knew tom banks when we were both at
the institute for advanced studying in
probably 1980 or something i haven't i'm
great i'm glad he's i'm glad he's doing
interesting things
and then uh the and the other point was
i mean uh
i don't want to dwell on all of these
but i presume that
uh if your program pans out we will want
to find
solutions to the classic puzzles of
particle physics so not just the cosmos
constant problem but the hierarchy
problem
you know the strong cp problem
bariogenesis uh
are these the kinds of things i i'm
guessing that i would have heard already
if you would solve them but maybe
are they solvable you think within the
program uh
you know eventually they should be i
mean we can we can start
teasing apart what each of them involves
i mean
you know the oh there are three
generations of particles
and um you know
the question is what's generic and
what's not so
the surprise for me is that general
relativity and quantum mechanics seem to
be generic
just as thermodynamics is generic and
the question is how far does the
generosity go
because i wouldn't have expected uh well
for example
i wouldn't have expected the the
detailed form of einstein's equations to
be as generic as they seem to be
so um and you know it could be
i i'm i have this vague suspicion
that the structure of the gate local
gauge group might be generic
i might be completely wrong about that
yeah that that that
you can hope um i i don't think the
three dimensions of space
are generic i don't think the three for
the three dimensions of space is generic
um whether the you know there are
bizarre possibilities like
you know maybe the two threes are
related you know the three generations
and the three dimensions of space maybe
uh you know and i don't know i mean that
that's a
um these things are all certainly
possible i think that
when it comes to things like um well one
example is cpt invariants
so that's a the question of why is there
cp invariance and i can explain a little
bit about that we don't know
completely i mean so in sort of in the
stack of things you need in particle
physics
a big feature of particle physics is
fermion versus bosons
you know particles like electrons but
are fermions and have the exclusion
principle don't want to be together
versus
photons which are bosons and are very
happy to be together
and those are distinguished by the you
know the spin statistics theorem says
if you are an uh you know if you're a
half entered spin particle
then you will be a fermion and if you're
an interesting particle you'll be a
boson
so one question is what are fermions and
bosons in our models
and can we derive the spin statistics
theorem and that's
an example of a sort of a you know one
of the achievements of quantum field
theory is the derivation of the spin
statistics theorem
um and uh so for us
uh fermions versus bosons we have a
guess we're not sure
the the guess has to do with in these
multi-way graphs
we suspect that bosons are associated
with
in a sense branchings that merge very
quickly
and fermions are associated with
branchings that do not merge quickly
and so that's what leads you in a sense
the the branchings that don't merge
quickly wind up with
opposite sides of branch shield space
things that can't happen effectively or
things that are not observed to happen
and and in fact at a mathematical level
it is
the the um you actually will then sort
of see
the fermions are kind of the square root
of the bosons because the fermions are
it just branches
it doesn't do the it doesn't merge as
well whereas the bosons are both the
branches and it merges
and so now the question is can we relate
that
to rotational symmetries that are
associated with
with the spins and so on and looking
promising
not done yet but looking so then then if
we can do that
then we can derive the spin statistics
theorem and um
uh then the next question is well cpt
invariance
just to explain for people the the um
this is a
fundamental symmetry that's believed to
exist in quantum field theory
is if you turn particles to
antiparticles you reflect space
and and you uh reverse time
then you'll always get something where
the laws of physics
work the same way so for us
again it's kind of neat because it seems
like
uh c charge conjugation which is
particle to antiparticle
is effectively like um
it is an it is an inversion in branch
hill space it seems to be
in other words it's a reflection in
branch hill space uh
uh parity is a as a reflection in
physical space
and time reversal is a reflection in
time and so what this is saying is
in the end that our multi-way causal
graph is invariant
under uh a reflection in all three of
those
uh in all three of those uh those
directions so to speak now we we
so it's at least a very clean
formulation of what it means to be cpt
invariant
whether we have not yet shown that we
necessarily get cpt invariants but at
least we know what it corresponds to
but that gives some sense so so when you
ask about cp violation for example
that's still a little ways away because
we don't yet understand cpt invariants
um in in regular quantum field theory
cpt
invariance is tightly connected to
lorenzen variants the invariants under
boosts and so forth
i'm guessing that in a discrete
graph model lorenzen variants must be
once again
approximate right and and it'll be at
some point even if it's very very
experimentally inaccessible where it
will break down absolutely there is a
maximum boost
you you can't get you know there's a in
other words as
eventually you start seeing the
granularity of space
yeah so you can you can do um uh
and so yes the the um the relationship
between that is that is in fact the
derivation path that we're aiming for
is causal invariance in the
ordinary causal graph leads to ordinary
lorenzen variants
and the guess is that some kind of the
causal invariance in the multi-way
causal graph
is associated with the essentially
extension of lorenzen variants
that is cpt invariants so that's that
that's the guess about how it works
right we don't know if that's really and
you know obviously cpt invariance
is a complicated story in general
relativity
and then non you know non non
you know non flat space time and so on
and and
no doubt we will run into those issues
there are very good experimental limits
on lorentz violation
from different propagation speeds of
photons of different wavelengths from
gamma-ray bursts
uh they can put limits up to the planck
scale but as you said your scale is much
tinier so it might not
be anywhere close right i mean i think
the thing that i'm most interested in
with respect to those propagation
experiments
is finding uh kind of uh dimension
fluctuations in the universe
because in our models the you know
there's no reason for the dimension to
always be three
in fact one of the things that's a
possibility is
so one of the more bizarre possibilities
again not properly explored
is that the einstein equations are
usually formulated in terms of change of
in terms of the change in curvature of
space
one possibility is you might be able to
say that curvature is always
zero but the dimension changes and
that's
and it might be that those are there is
some mathematical equivalence between
those for small curvatures small
dimension changes
but but but you know one of the things
that we suspect in our models
is that the universe started infinite
dimensional and only gradually
sort of cooled down to be
three-dimensional and so that
then a lot of the problems about you
know these horizon problems in the early
universe and so on
disappear because when it's infinite
dimensional
everything is closely connected the
graph distance between things is small
now the suspicion from this is that as
it cools down
to be three-dimensional there may be
dimension fluctuations left over
and so obviously you know the question
is would those be visible at the time of
recombination
can we see that in the microwave and the
cosmic microwave background
of course we don't know but the the the
first question is what would a dimension
fluctuation
do to the cosmic microarray background
and then if there was a dimension
fluctuation that exists
in the current universe what would it do
to the propagation of a photon through
that dimension
that region of dimension fluctuation and
i this is
this is a piece of in a sense classical
physics that i keep on meaning to work
out and i keep on hoping somebody else
is going to work it out
because it's kind of like that i've been
i've been collecting this inventory of
of uh
laws of physics and d dimensions well i
think i mean i'm just guessing here so i
haven't thought of it myself but
um if the effective dimensionality space
is not exactly three
coulomb's law would not be exactly true
and wouldn't that have dramatic effects
on qed scattering rates
um well the question is something like
the thompson cross section for example
does
how does that depend on so uh
i am well you you're
you're correct that in d-dimensional
space so so the way to think about i
think
photon propagation is using huygens
principle
where you're saying that every on this
wavefront of a propagating
a propagating uh you know light wave or
whatever
every every point on that wavefront is a
source of a spherical
wave that is going to build up the next
piece of the wave front
and if you are in d-dimensional space
where d isn't three
those little spherical waves have a
different
you know there's a different density on
those spherical waves
so to speak when you project them into
three dimensions that's at least my
thinking about how to do this now
question is so the question is so so in
particle physics
back when i used to do particle physics
a long time ago i was a big enthusiast
of this method called dimensional
regularization
which is the idea that you know well
you're doing an integral
and if it's if the dimensionality of
space time is four
the integral diverges horribly but if we
can only say it's four minus epsilon
we can do the integral and then we take
the limit epsilon goes to zero at the
end
so i'm sure i've worked out back in the
day what the low energy electron photon
scattering cross section is in d
dimensions
and that's a that would be a good um uh
that would be a good case to look at i
mean i think that that
that i will not be surprised if there is
some
thing that one can some fairly sensitive
test of the dimensionality of space for
example i don't know
and i've been meaning to look it up what
um uh
the anomalous magnetic moment of the
electron or the muon
um you know it's it's one minus alpha
over two pi
but that certainly depends on the
dimension of space i just don't know how
yeah there's probably some sensitive
particle height high
particle physics experiment that that is
uh sensitive to that so
okay i think i only have two questions
but they're both huge questions so i
suspect they're going to take more than
two minutes each but uh
one of them is you you referred to this
idea that in the early universe
uh maybe we have some bundle of
dimensionality or dimensionality is not
well defined and that sort of comes out
in the wash as the evolution happens
um so i've thought very much about the
arrow of time problem but i've thought
about
it in the context of fundamentally
reversible
directionless laws of physics which is a
little bit different from where you're
coming
from so for me the huge question is
you know we're evolving toward an
equilibrium
empty space situation where all the
galaxies are all dissolved around we
have nothing around us but the
cosmological horizon
and that's the highest entropy state uh
but we came from
14 billion years ago a very very very
low entropy state and in conventional
cosmology there's just
no good explanation for that except the
papers i've written
and even those are not universally
accepted yet but it sounds like you have
a possible
completely different point of view where
it's just natural that you start with
what we would expose facto label
low entropy so i think the the
discussion about entropy is kind of
confusing
okay that's my first statement i i
remember
actually i remember having this vigorous
arguments with dick hyman about
this very topic of whether the universe
was you know he made this claim
the universe is a fluctuation you know
the fact that we are
in this state where we're not kind of
you know where we aren't at
sort of the maximally disordered state
now i kept on saying
that's just a completely crazy claim
because it's like everything we know is
a fluctuation
so you know i think i i would be more
eloquent these days than i was back
um i'm on your side yeah
and explaining why that was such a such
a a a wrong idea but anyway
no the first the first thing to
understand is that
people say oh you know eventually the
universe will kind of unwind and
there'll be nothing interesting
there'll be no structure in it it will
all just be in a high entropy state
okay my claim is the reason you say that
is because you're not an adequate demon
that is
in fact in the future of the universe if
it turns out that it's all just seems
like a gas in equilibrium and so on
that you might say that's completely
boring that's all just random it's the
high entropy state
but to another kind of observer they
might say but look at all those little
details about what's happening
this is the most amazing complex
structure
that you can imagine i mean i i happen
to think if
if we ask what will we look back on this
time in scientific history
and say how could those guys have missed
this point my guess is one of the bigger
things will be
when people describe something like a
gas and thermal equilibrium
they just say it has a certain pressure
and temperature they don't consider
any other features of the gas they don't
say oh it's got these little microscopic
you know things that we can measure in
this way in that way but my guess is
that there are
a lot of other features now this
question of are they computationally
boundedly observable
are they are they measurable by a
computationally bounded observer
i don't know the answer to that really
um but
the the the point the claim i'm making
is that when you say it's going to a
high entropy state
you're saying oh that all you're saying
is
so i as a as a as an observer of the
kind of observer i am
can't make anything out of it other than
to say it's uniform and random
i think i'm actually saying more than
that i think in this case i'm going to
disagree with you because i think that
it
actually goes to the vacuum quantum
state the
the bunch davis vacuum of dissider space
it's it's
uh we it's a dissipative system because
there are uh there's a horizon around us
and within our horizon all the
excitations above the vacuum
go away and and there's no structure
there to be seen by any observer uh
computationally what do you think is in
the vacuum
well it's a single quantum state
thinking in quantum mechanical terms
it's a unique quantum state the lowest
energy state
that's so i would claim that's the
mistake and it may be interesting to try
and take that apart
so in our models the very fact that
there's space there
space is a thing in our models you have
to make space you don't just get to say
oh there's this big area of space space
is made of something
and in our models space is made of this
sort of teeming collection of atoms of
space doing all these
complicated things so our vacuum cannot
be
just the boring there's nothing there
vacuum
our vacuum has to have a lot of
structure in it now
if you ask the question if you say uh
every particle excitation has gone over
the horizon
that's what you're basically saying so
let's think about that for a second what
does that mean
in in our models so horizons in our
models
are visible in essentially uh
breaks in the causal graph so the causal
graph says
this is the you know causal effects can
propagate
between these between these at this
event can affect this prevent can affect
this event
and you make these light cones where one
event is having an effect on a whole
sort of increasing size cone of other
events
right so what is a what is an event
horizon an event horizon is and you
literally see this in our models when
you run them
and like these black holes you can
literally see the event horizon and it's
a place where the causal edges
for example in a black hole the causal
edges go one way
because the ledges go in and they can't
come out and that's
it's very concrete and so a cosmological
event horizon
is something where you're separating in
the causal graph you have two different
regions of the causal graph and they are
you simply have no causal edges that go
from one side to the other
so what you would be saying is what what
you're claiming is
every particle excitation has somehow
is is in a region of space that is
causally disconnected from the region of
space that
that we care about so to speak so i
think my
my statement would be it's i mean your
claim is an interesting one because
basically what you're saying is that all
the big particle excitations
all these sort of identifiable
topological excitations
will be gone and outside the you know
outside of this event horizon
now what i would be saying is that in
order for there to be space
inside there there still has to be stuff
going on now
what so what this turns into is an
argument about
is is there stuff
that is there useful stuff in that
region of the universe
and by useful stuff you might say it's
this complicated topological structure
that represents a photon but that
depends on
you know and so you say the observer an
observer
that you know about right now is
observing things like photons is
observing these big
complicated topological structures but
you know
in terms of the pure underlying
structure of the universe
you could still have all these little
atoms of space doing their thing
it's just maybe maybe it's smoothed out
enough
conceivably that there aren't any of
these sort of identifiable topologically
stable structures
that still exist there that's a possible
that's a possible kind of uh
and then the observer would have to be
at the demon level so to speak
in order to observe that there's
anything interesting happening there
and not at a level if the observer is
made of particles for example is made of
photons
that might be the case that you you
couldn't get with an observer made of
photons
you simply couldn't get information
about that more microscopic structure
so yeah i think we should uh postpone
this to either um
an in-person conversation or me
appearing on your podcast because
uh it does get kind of technical at some
point but i i don't want to
uh not give you an opportunity to talk
about the beginning of the universe you
talked about the end there
uh but is there is i i i i'm gonna guess
that you're going to say that there is a
principled reason within this approach
to
start in what looks something like very
roughly the big bang
well okay so the question is what you
know
in these models okay this gets us into
another
this is a deep rabbit hole that we're
about to enter but let me let me say a
few things about it because it's
something i've recently been thinking a
lot about
the the um so
uh the
okay so in these models
you might imagine that the universe
starts as a fairly small hypograph
and gradually expands and so one of the
mistakes i've been trying to not
make is kind of a repeat of the einstein
mistake so to speak
because in our models the most natural
thing is that this hypergraph just
expands
dramatically with time okay and
you know i'm i'm not i i have a great
tendency and this is kind of a reverse
engineering type tendency to say
no no there's got to be these other
rules that reduce the size of the
hypograph
so that it doesn't expand insanely you
know just like einstein was saying
well you know even though the einstein
equations predict the universe should
expand of course we know it doesn't
expand
except it turns out actually we
discovered it does expand so i'm trying
to not repeat that mistake
but um uh you know i think that
the current expectation would be
that just as there's a simple rule so
also there's a simple initial condition
and that is a small hypograph and which
is something that
doesn't really even define a dimension
because it's just a tiny little
hypograph
and it starts expanding and at the
beginning
that expansion is like you know is is uh
is something which effect it has high
dimension then it goes down so one of
the things we've been trying to do which
is
probably more in your in your day job
wheelhouse so to speak
is we'd really like to know what the
analog of the friedman robertson walker
model of the universe is for dimension
change
so we were pretty sure that there is a
an analogue for a homogeneous isotropic
universe
that there's something just like the
usual model just as it's homogeneous and
the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic
so what does the scale factor of the
universe what does that you know how
does that
how does that work with time we're
pretty sure there's a directly analogous
thing
that describes dimension change in the
universe and that will be the
effective equations that describe in our
models the very early universe
yeah and i think there it's actually
i'll just sort of mention
a couple of things uh for your benefit
as well for the audiences
uh if you want to imagine you have a
bunch of dimensions that start small
and some of them start expanding there's
a very set of
cute models from brandenburger and waffa
based on string theory but they have a
way why only three
dimensions of space would start
expanding and it's basically because you
can tie your shoes in three dimensions
but not in four dimensions right strings
will generically intersect in three
dimensions but not higher numbers of
dimensions so that was there i wrote
that down i'm going to look that up
yeah that's a fun one the duel of that
the converse was actually
uh by me and lisa randall and matt
johnson where we showed how
if you start with higher dimensional
decider space
you could actually create a subuniverse
with fewer
macroscopic dimensions by spontaneously
compactifying
some dimensions so i think dynamically
given
curved space time you're allowed to go
either way you can have them all small
and let some grow or you can have them
all big and let
some shrink oh it's interesting i mean
you know in in the the question is if
it's homogeneous and isotopic whatever
the generalization of that for dimension
change is
what i expect is that there's going to
be some equation
that eventually will have the dimension
and the scale factor in it
and it will be a only those things so
you don't
in the things you were just describing
there's presumably non-homogeneity
because you're saying that there are
some
you know pieces some dimensions that
grow some that shrink
and so on this would be kind of the
homogeneous isotropic analog of that
i mean i think this is a in a sense this
is a quintessential
not particularly easy mathematical
physics problem but it is
in a sense it's it's the reason one
reason it's not easy and
perhaps of perhaps interesting to say is
that
calculus which is what all of this stuff
is based on
is a story of changes with respect to a
variable like time
but in our models and you know when
people do multivariate calculus
they're doing calculus with you know
with two variables or three variables
but they never get to do calculus with
two and a half variables
that's not a thing and nobody knows how
that works
and um so in our models what we
effectively have to do
is go below the level of where we talk
about variables
and we're actually in our hypographs you
can think about a direction in the
hypograph
as being like a variable so as you move
through the hypergraph
in a certain direction that's like a
variable but if the hypergraph is a big
mess
it's not obvious what you mean by a
direction if the hypergraph was a nice
orderly like crystal-like thing
then you'd have a well-defined notion of
direction but in the actual hypergraph
you don't
right and that's and that's kind of
where you begin i mean that there needs
to be
a generalization of calculus made that
works in fractional dimensional space on
these hypographs and so on
and that's kind of the that's the
technical difficulty of this but
but that's i mean it's interesting i'm
i'm going to look up that that
that reference that's that's that's very
useful well good and and i think this
leads actually very naturally into the
final
uh big issue i wanted to address um
which is
locality and you know you've talked a
lot i think even though i never
got to sort of specifically ask i think
you've done a good job of explaining how
space time arises and einstein's
equation and general relativity and as
you said
three dimensions doesn't seem to
magically come out but maybe we can
figure that we get it with the right
rules so that that's future
work good um but locality is an
interesting thing by locality i just
mean the fact that in
space uh the laws of physics for the
most part
have the property that if you poke the
system in one location of space
the effects ripple out locally right
only to nearest neighbors as you go
forward in time
so that's one thing you might want to
get out of an approach
like yours is that you have this notion
of locality quantum field theory is
based on locality
but in the real world there's at least
two interesting places where we think
locality breaks down one is in quantum
measurement
with bell's inequality right and the
other is potentially in quantum gravity
with the holographic principle
complementarity ads cfd
uh so what is your feeling about how you
can thread that needle
of getting enough locality out of your
rules but
also slight deviations from locality
when you need them
okay my current guess is the following
in space and physical
what in these hypergraphs we are saying
there's a a certain clump of
of nodes in the hypergraph that have
this structure they get transformed into
one with that structure
that's an essential local in space in
the sense that it involves this local
region of nodes in the hypergraph
okay now there's two kinds of locality
one is spatial locality
and the other is bronchial locality in
other words is it
and so my guess is and the way that
things like bell's inequality that the
violation of bells and equality come out
is through non that that that
branchial space is differently laid out
than physical space physical space we we
know in this hypergraph
that it's you know we are we are
choosing to a rule
that is local with respect to the
hypograph but the question of what
counts as local
in this in in branchial space locality
is a different story
locality is a story there of well it's a
is it just a different kind of thing
because it involves these
the ancestry uh ancestry and the
multi-way graph and so on
so i think the the um the story there
is uh locality and bronze shield space
is a different issue
and for example you can ask what's the
analog of a light cone in brown shield
space
so in physical space you know you make a
perturbation somewhere
it expands at the speed of light what
happens in branch hill space
well it also expands at finite speed in
our models
and that means there is a maximum
entanglement speed in quantum mechanics
and um uh that the the the value of that
we only need we only have one parameter
we really need
so if we knew the elementary length or
if we knew the elementary time or the
elementary energy
right or if we knew the maximum
entanglement speed any
you know any one of those parameters is
enough to determine
the length scale for our models um but
uh
the this maximum entanglement speed is
saying
in branchial space you have a
um you know one vague estimate that we
have is the
the uh maximum entanglement speed is 10
to the five solar masses per second
i don't know if that's correct that's
based on a very hokey
calculation that i did which makes a
bunch of assumptions
um but it gives you some sense of scale
if
if that was the right value we would
observe we would observe
limitations on black hole mergers of big
black holes or very rapid mergers
that are associated with maximum
entanglement speed rather than speed of
light
so in a sense it's a limit of the rate
of quantum measurement
or the rate of quantum effects and so
one question
is uh which we were just thinking about
recently
is can we actually bound in other words
in
in these violation of bells inequality
experiments where you're looking at
propagation of physical space and you're
saying it seems to happen
instantaneously in physical space
well because the reason that's happening
is because that
propagation so to speak is actually
happening in our models in bronze shield
space
which is a different story than physical
space but
if we knew the maximum entanglement
speed we might be able to make
bounds on that speed in physical space
which would mean that even though you
know these these various
bells and equality you know entanglement
experiments and so on
are uh much you know they seem
instantaneous so to speak
that actually there might be a finite
bound we're not sure about that yet
i think it's probably not exactly the
same but this is certainly spiritually a
similar answer to what an everettian
would give to the whole bells inequality
question there's there's not a unique
measurement outcome in in space so uh
the
the rules that bell was assuming do not
necessarily apply
right i mean i think that so and so by
the way this maximum entanglement speed
has all kinds of consequences so for
example
you can have entanglement horizons so
you can have a
a um essentially a horizon and branch
real space
and so one of the things we suspect we
don't yet know is that there's an
entanglement horizon
outside of the physical event horizon
in black holes and so what that means is
so so far we can get
black holes in our single thread of
history
uh you know not dealing with multi-way
causal graphs
it's just a technically difficult thing
to do the analogous
calculation for a multi-way graph but we
think we'll be able to do that
and at that point we will see black
holes that have an event horizon
in physical space and an event horizon
in branchial space
and so the question is and that is an
interesting thing because
you know if you think about the
propagation of information in the
history of a black hole
there's a question of can information be
trapped between the entanglement horizon
and the physical event horizon and that
and so one of the questions is if you're
an observer falling into a black hole
and you're you know when you when you're
an observer falling into a black
hole to the outside world you know time
has stopped
for you know your and so the question is
what's the analogous thing that happens
in the entanglement horizon
and i think what happens it's kind of
cute i think
what happens is that the observer at the
entanglement horizon
cannot form a classical thought
so i'm sorry from the from the
observer's point of view they just fall
right through though in classical gr
yes yes right but to a person correct so
that is to a person far away from the
entanglement horizon
they would conclude that the observer at
the entanglement horizon
could not form a classical thought so
that means
they could never in the in the sort of
traditional quantum mechanics world they
could never collapse the wave function
they could never and so what would
happen is for them
you know they they're that they're
observing you know some virtual particle
pair
you know you know did that did that
electron go into the black hole or not
well they don't know because they can't
form the classical thought
to determine whether it went into the
black hole or not and so that's how
that's our kind of at least qualitative
thinking
about um uh sort of black hole
information paradox kinds of things in
our models
i i would suspect that that that um
i know i haven't worked on this but
jonathan gorhart has worked a bunch on
the er equals epr
story in our models and uh claims that
he is about to produce
an actual sort of explicit uh simulation
of an
er equals epr thing so
that that term uh which has been i mean
that it's an imminent claim so it will
have a rise
that's fine low maybe by the time the
episode comes out but
it does remind me of a potential and i
promise is the last thing a potential
quantitative question um
the entropy of a black hole is its
horizon area
divided by four measured in planck units
according to hawking and beckenstein
um someone like me would interpret that
as saying that the black hole is
described by
a factor of hilbert space with
a dimensionality approximately e to that
number
uh but the planck length is not
fundamental for you is there any chance
that you would be able to
calculate the beckenstein hawking
entropy and get the right answer
yeah that's an interesting question so i
mean in
uh you know
the notion of what black hole entropy is
what is entropy
entropy is basically a measure of the
number of states
the number of microscopic states of a
system consistent with the macroscopic
thing that you identify as being the
system so to speak
so this is basically saying given this
thing that we say
as a black hole how many possible
microscopic states are consistent with
this
macroscopic observation that it is a
black hole so
i would think that
we should be able to compute that um
and let me think how would we uh
yeah i mean i i can imagine how we would
compute that
um and i think it will you know what we
have to do
okay so in space-time we can
see these event horizons in the causal
graph you can explicitly i've even
studied them a bunch and you can see all
kinds of exotic black holes inside black
holes and all kinds of
interesting and wild things that can
happen um but
uh the i i started looking at the
multi-way version of that
it's just computationally hard because
that what's happening is
you you're you've got these you know
it's for the exact reason you've got
this big
exponential in there yeah you've got
this you know all these different
threads of history
that you have to account for and as i
say there is an optimization of this
that another person working on this
project max piskanov has been working on
for the most of the last year actually
um which is the theory of local
multi-weight systems
which are systems so so um
uh the idea is
okay so so roughly the idea is the
following so you have
uh in when you're looking at this causal
graph
that represents all these different
events and they're happening through
time
and you say i'm going to take a slice of
this chordal graph at a particular
what i consider to be a particular
moment in time then i've got a structure
of space
associated with those causal connections
and so on
that is that is getting us a version of
space when we also have this multi-way
graph
there are there are many different
configurations for space
but so there's this notion that i was
calling multi-space
which is this thing where every place in
space there's also
essentially this stack of multi-way
possibilities
and what's difficult is to understand we
can say okay there's this multi-ray
graph and the whole universe is one node
in this multi-wave graph
or we can say we've got one path in the
multi-ray graph and now we're going to
look at what happens in space
but the the the thing we're trying to do
is to see how do we
get a representation that knits those
two things together
where we are looking at locality in
space
and essentially locality and branchial
space and being able to
to sort of have those two things
combined if we can successfully do this
i'm pretty sure we can do essentially
numerical quantum field theory
and we can do it in you know in the
traditional way this is done it's either
feynman diagrams or it's lattice gauge
theory
lattice gauge there is an imaginary time
which is kind of a
you know not great and um in
in this in this setup we will be able to
do it in actual time
and and we'll be able to do it and then
you know the question of whether we see
sort of motivation theory and finding
diagram is a story of what happens with
our you know with our topological
excitations and so on that might be a
more complicated story
but anyway that that's a um uh uh yeah i
mean
the the thing that's really to me
you know just tremendously exciting
about this whole thing
is you know there's this underlying
structure and we keep on being able to
figure out more and more stuff it's not
easy to figure out these things
but it's like nothing is we're not
ending up running into something where
we say oh my gosh
that's you know we just can't explain
that that's just a thing which just is
you know totally orthogonal to what our
models are saying
and that's some and the other thing
that's happening which
i think is that we keep on running into
things which say oh
that's just like causal set theory oh
that's just like
you know constructor theory or whatever
oh that's just like
one of these other theories that's been
developed and
what's you know to me both
intellectually and sociologically
a terrific thing is that you know the
results that people have developed in
these theories
like take causal set theory for example
there's been kind of a mystery you know
you're just throwing down events in
space time
and you're saying just look at the
relationship between those events
in a causal graph but there's been kind
of a mystery
why are the event thrown down in just
such a way that you get lorenzen
variants
yeah well in our models we have an
algorithmic procedure for generating
those events
which immediately gives you lorenzen
variants but yet
the all the mathematics that people have
done in causal set theory
which works on arbitrary collections of
events in space time
can be applied to our models and so
that's a that's a
really neat thing and i i'm you know
it's looking and the same thing
i mean we've been uh in higher category
theory
is another you know very elaborate area
of mathematics
which is i mean our stuff is a
concretization
is a concrete instance of higher
category theory
and all kinds of rewards that exist in
higher category theory that have been
extremely abstract
basically my test is i can now
understand a bunch of these results
which i've never been able to do before
so because they have a concrete
instantiation and you know one of the
things which which we are not going to
have a chance to talk about here but the
question of
of of um which we sort of started to
talk about is
why this universe and not another one
you know why does this universe exist at
all
uh that we seem to be able to have some
things to say about
and it turns out that it's all to do
with this
limit of higher category theory which
turns out to also be
this limit of running all possible rules
in a multi-way graph
and these are things related to this
thing
called the infinity groupoid which was
to you know
uh introduced by this chap grothen deek
who was a very
um abstract abstruse mathematician and i
never thought i would have any reason to
care about the infinity group void
except that it seems that it is the
limit of a bunch of our models
and uh it seems that it's it's deeply
related to a lot of things about
sort of why this universe and and why
does the universe exist anyway
and uh you know just as a teaser of
something we're not going to have a
chance to talk about but
but one of the things that i've been
excited about recently
is just as we are making this sort of
foundational model for physics
i would like to make a foundational
model of mathematics
and we're talking about the set of all
possible rules for the physical universe
you can also talk about the set of all
possible rules in mathematics
and one of my recent conclusions is if
we believe that the universe exists
which presumably we do
because that's a notion of existence
that we are
pretty familiar with then it necessarily
follows
that mathematics exists in the same way
and that our
doing of mathematics is kind of carving
out
pieces of this kind of structure that is
all the mathematics
in much the same way that we're kind of
carving out pieces of the universe to
observe but anyway
that's a that's a that's a a coming
attraction as yet um
uh i mean i what i want to do is to find
a bulk theory of metamathematics
in the same way that we have bulk
theories like relativity and quantum
mechanics
and physics well i can i can tell you
that uh
it was just a couple months ago that we
had a podcast episode with emily real
a mathematician from johns hopkins a
category theorist and we talked about
the infinity group
oh good very good we talked about the
infinity group void which tells me both
that there's a unity to all of knowledge
but also there's a plenty of room to go
which i think that everyone uh listening
to this episode will definitely get that
impression so
stephen wolfram thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
that was fun good stuff
[Music]
you